No
Bush,
Yo,
peace man.
No,
Hey fuckers,
put your pants.
But my pants were on.
I found the name of the guy who does those fucking kettlebells.
Finally,
Jesus Christ that was driving me nuts.
So the Ani Kettlebells,
kettlebells,
kettle bells are made by Steven Shubin,
Steven Shubin,
who is actually Aubrey stepbrother and he's got a shop out in New Mexico where
they make the Onnit kettle bells,
the primal bell's a that you've seen with the awesome Carrillo face.
The new one,
uh,
rang a Tang,
which a $5 of everyone,
the proceeds go to help save orangutans.
They're in endangered species.
Um,
and then of course the chimpanzee,
which is 35 pounds,
I think probably they're all in dangerous,
right?
I mean,
and one way or another.
they're only alive because we,
we make sure that people don't kill too many of them.
They have a real problem with it.
In Africa.
They call it bushmeat and they kill chimpanzees.
I was like,
reading this,
uh,
this piece on,
on bushmeat various monkeys of the kill and eat.
They just fucking eat everything they catch and they don't,
they don't give a shit.
I guess in certain parts of Africa I should probably be specific.
But in certain parts of Africa,
they don't give a shit apparently about what's legal or illegal.
Um,
anyway,
that's neither here nor there.
These are not real monkeys,
but they look bad ass and the help your fitness,
they're uh,
if you've never worked out with kettle bells,
um,
we have,
uh,
a workout video,
two of them,
the extreme kettlebell cardio,
a DVD by Keith Weber one and two.
Um,
but I always suggest and it gets repetitive,
but unfortunately I can't be assured that you've listened to every one of these.
Um,
so if you,
uh,
are thinking about doing any kind of workout routine with weights at least once
or twice,
go to a trainer,
go to a trainer and have someone teach you how to do the moves correctly.
Start with low weights.
Work your way up.
Trust me.
It's a weird way of working out kettlebells and club bells and things along
those lines.
They're,
they're really awkward.
They put a lot of,
uh,
strange strain on your body that you might not be used to and it requires a good
form for all of those activities.
You don't want to get injured,
injury suck,
especially ones that you could have avoided if you did it.
Smart.
Trust me,
I've done that.
Have injured myself like an idiot.
It's a terrible feeling.
You just feel stupid and you know,
hopefully you learn,
but better.
Learn from other people,
learn from other people and just be really diligent about it.
There's plenty of,
uh,
videos,
on,
on itself.
You can see there's one here with a,
our pal Aubrey,
where he's going to teach some of the basics of kettlebells.
And if you know how he's doing it,
he's doing it with a very light kettlebell.
That's a 35 pounder.
You don't want to get crazy.
Trust me.
You can get a really good workout in with a,
a fairly light cut kettlebell.
There's one that I do the k,
the Kettlebell cardio extreme workout.
I do that fucking thing with for 35 pound Kettlebell e a manly man
like myself.
Joe Is ovary wearing those feces.
Yes,
these are awesome girls wearing the feces and the guy,
the worst defeat sees what you don't work for you.
Are you serious?
Absolutely.
You've got some ugg boots too.
Don't you know I love boots cause there you're supposed to work out barefoot.
Steve Maxwell,
famed fitness trainer told me that,
uh,
the real way to use your,
your feet and keep your feet strong and like activate all your muscles is you're
supposed to be barefoot.
That's how you're supposed to run.
It's how are you supposed to do everything?
And that's why there's a move to a minimalist running shoe and running on the
ball of the foot.
Now instead of the heel,
when they created these running shoes,
he's really cool running shoes with the springs in the back of them they changed
a human's gate because most people's running gait is not heal first.
It's actually like if you watch like little kids run,
they run and sort of cushion the impact with the ball of their foot and their
foot acts as a shock absorber.
If you're just running,
he'll first,
you're not getting that shock absorber you just slamming down,
uh,
on your heel into the ground.
And the way that was made possible is because of those fat sold running shoes.
And they actually changed the way people run.
You really supposed to run on those things.
He's supposed to run the ball your foot first.
And that's what,
and if you did that,
then another thing would happen is you wouldn't want to run on concrete.
He would realize it.
You'd be like,
Ooh,
this is like,
this is stupid.
Like this doesn't exist in nature.
You know?
Dirts okay,
you can run on a nice dirt road and it's okay,
but running on concrete,
it's like,
boy,
I mean you can do it,
but after a while it's going to,
you're paying a toll and unnecessary told him my opinion,
you're not wearing these like out.
They all garden zero fucks to give zero fucks on.
Have you ever worn those footsies with your,
uh,
Pennypack I'm sure I have.
Absolutely.
It's at the gym.
Yeah.
At the same time and making it a lot of grunts and sexual noises.
While I'm lifting weights.
That's rare.
Like bigfoot.
I give no,
no,
no.
It's very common.
Well,
it's common.
You'll find it.
You'll find it anywhere where there's a men who don't give a fuck and know what
the correct footwear is.
If they tell you you have to wear shoes at the gym,
you're really supposed to wear those things,
those little footie things.
I liked the Filo.
One's a fairly nice,
have you been worried?
Have you worn the fanny pack feet seats with the,
the chain wallet?
No.
All right.
That would be,
that'd be the Loch ness monster real?
Yeah.
Well the chain wall was in the fanny pack.
I mean,
uh,
no.
I put it in there so I don't have to like from at the gym,
I could put everything in the bag.
If I'm traveling,
I put everything in the bag,
the fanny pack.
What?
It's really good for us airports.
You put everything in your bag,
boom.
It goes through the radar detector.
He put it back on.
Right.
It's way easier than dumping your keys out in trays.
It's easy to get things and you sit on the plane.
You looking for your iPhone dunes right there.
You pull it up.
See Science.
It's just looks goofy.
That's what you just can't be afraid of looking goofy.
I put a picture on my Instagram the other day,
this old man up I probably shouldn't have.
I didn't ask this promotion that.
Did he say anything to you?
Because he looked like he was looking right at,
you know,
taking a photo.
But it was rocking and hard and I had to give him his props.
He probably thought I was making fun of them,
but in reality I was giving them prompts.
If I didn't actually wear a fanny pack myself,
I would feel bad.
But I did it.
But I don't see,
I think we should go the opposite.
I think we like,
we need to bring back like the pockets in the shoes but make them bigger so you
could put your cell phones in there,
like make bigger shoes in the shoes.
I remember those.
What are those Kangaroos?
Oh,
I don't remember those at all.
I do.
Now that you brought it up,
they would like the tongue had like a zipper in or some crazy.
What a dumb idea.
So in front of me.
A lot of money on that though.
People who wear that shit for a while
still make those shoes.
I see.
They still make these,
well this is a toddler one.
If you're betting on futures.
I put some money in fanny packs.
I think that bitch is coming back.
Oh,
those are Kangaroos on the sides.
You put your key.
Yeah,
but what if they make them bigger?
So it's like,
like you're wearing boots again,
kind of cowboy boots,
but they're just more like a man purse and your shoe place to put things.
So it'd be rattling around up against your leg.
The correct place is the fanny pack.
That's what a lot of people don't want to admit.
It's the right way to do it.
It's the easiest way to get to.
It's all right here.
Don't have to reach around and not wearing a fucking satchel pretending it's on
a purse.
It's a Satchel.
I like.
I'm a man of the city and I wear a Satchel.
I get off my 10 speed bike.
I have my lock with my Satchel.
Yeah,
satchels.
Nice.
Is nothing wrong with it.
We've,
we've done this ramp before cause nothing wrong with it.
It's nothing wrong with a Satchel or a purse.
You want to wear a purse?
Who gives a fuck?
If you give a shit,
if a guy's wearing a leather bag covered in rhinestones,
you're an asshole.
Yeah.
But sometimes it looks really great.
Like that's just a person.
It's a burst no matter what.
But because it's flat,
it's okay.
We are so stupid.
People are so stupid.
At Hertz,
we're so dumb that we give a fuck about the shape of the bag that you carry in
your shoulder and whether or not it makes you feminine.
That's how fucking stupid we are.
If it,
if it's flat,
it's a laptop.
But if it's rounded,
Eh,
you a PA Uva prayer.
Faith.
What's in the bag,
buddy?
It's a laptop.
Oh well you're allowed to carry it like that.
If it was just makeup and shit,
what's in the bag?
Oh,
just penises.
Various penises have collected throughout the day.
I'm a penis hunter.
Yeah.
What do you carrying in there?
If you Karen rocks,
nobody can say shit.
If you got like a fucking canvas Satchel filled with rocks and one's going to
call it a purse,
right?
But you also carry your sandwich in there and your keys with the rocks sandwich
gets all fucked up though in men or hey,
slice it Jesus Christ and,
and what we're talking about,
you started off talking about supplements on a.com o.N ,N ,
I t,
use a code name Brogan.
Save yourself 10% off any and all supplements if you haven't been there before.
We got a lot of cool new shit in there.
So go check it out.
Go to [inaudible] dot com get up on it.
We're also brought to you by stamps.com yeah,
just because I said get up on it.
That made the commercial 15% more douche on it.
It at least,
at least it's if,
if we had like a song,
get up on end
up on it and grab it like you want it whenever you promoting anything.
There's an air of gross and it's to it.
Even if what you're selling is awesome,
just comes out grows.
It just seems gross so there's no way to do commercials that aren't a little
gross,
but people have to realize that it doesn't mean the product isn't good.
Like stamps.com we've said it many,
many times before.
It's way easier than going to the post office.
One of the reasons why they were one of our sponsors is because it makes sense.
It's,
it's a great product.
If you run your own business,
if you have your own business,
you can go to your home computer,
you weigh your shit out on a scale that they provide.
You print up the postals thing,
the postman comes,
you put it on the packages and you're off to the races.
You don't have to go anywhere and I'm waiting in line.
All that ridiculous silly bullshit.
Mailing and shipping can be a very challenging thing if you're making constant
trips to the post office.
But stamps.com can just sorta do everything the postdocs can do right inside
your house.
And if you go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of the homepage.
This one of those old schooly microphones that if you're a classy comedian,
you will use and your headshot
and use the code word j,
r e and uh,
you will save yourself some money with,
they're $110 bonus offer.
It includes a digital scale,
enough to $55 in free postage.
I'm Brian needs to stamps.com for all those t shirts,
all the death squads,
teachers that you've seen from a desk,
squad.tv.
All those are sent from stamps.com it's literally that easy.
Can you believe it is literally that easy?
I hate people that use literally and then I'm using it.
Speech folks,
even though it can be annoying,
is oftentimes just sort of automatic.
Okay?
It's not indicative of you being an asshole if you use literally,
but sometimes someone has to tell you,
hey,
fuck,
head stopped saying literally after everything,
you're killing my brain.
Nothing wrong with that.
Either.
stamps.com code word jre and seen this weekend.
I'll be at the Brayer Improv this Friday,
Saturday and Sunday with the lovely and talented Tony Hinchcliffe Avi
and with Tony a the 26 in Phoenix,
Arizona.
Bad.
Stand up,
live following day 27th I'll be in Columbus,
Ohio at Thompson,
Christina Palicki
and Tony.
Oh,
good googly Mowgli son.
And a crazy show.
It's a Goddamn road trip.
Those are good road trips right there that stand up.
Lives at Groin Club,
man.
Holy Shit.
That place is awesome.
It's so huge.
It's kind of a daunting size.
It's awesome though.
So cool that there's,
you know,
we're so lucky.
There's so many cool clubs like that that are out there.
There's one of the beautiful things about being a standup.
You can travel and totally spots,
do all these different cool ass clubs.
Anyway.
Um,
that's it.
That's where we be.
Your fucks.
I'm also,
uh,
in Toronto.
Um,
on,
uh,
I think the 19th,
I can't say my desktop.
Yeah,
the night the 19th.
I'm in Toronto with Brian Cowen and Tommy Segora.
Oh,
Jesus.
Christmas.
That's right.
You fucking Canadian freaks.
We're bringing the thunder.
I got so much shit to talk to people about.
It's been an interesting few months down here in America.
I like to go up to Canada because they love shit on America.
That's why.
That's why,
that's where I get off my best America jokes,
self deprecating American jokes.
So I love America folks.
Not pretending I'm not wanting,
not like I'm trying to draw in Canada.
Why don't you just go to kid once?
You each go up,
dude,
you fucking love him so much.
Why don't you marry Canada?
It's the highlight of what I just said.
Is it people that are taking themselves too fucking serious these days?
We've got a real problem with it will be real fucking problem with it.
People just looking to get pissed off about nothing all day.
Everyone just looking to get pissed off every fucking youtube comment and conti
Twitter name reflects this.
It's everywhere.
Everybody just needs to chill.
What are you showing this girl for?
I made it.
I made this girl last night,
that massage.
Thanks.
Should I wear my shirt after I was done with her?
Brian,
are you serious?
No,
that's the Rosie Rosie train comedian.
Excuse me.
As silly bitch
bitch out
experience.
Ge.
Ah,
hello friends,
neighbors
fucker when you do and we're doing it old school.
Just me and Brian Today.
We're just sitting around and we decided to do a podcast just like,
like day one,
day one,
the old old school days.
And that's the disgusting sip of coffee that people complain about the most.
We're just talking about that man.
There's a lot of God damn complaints in this world.
A lot of people are mad.
All the folks on God,
like productions.com I'm so sorry I upset you.
I did not mean to you.
And uh,
although we disagree on things folks,
I think we can be civil.
I really do you think I'm an idiot because I don't believe what you believe.
I'm okay.
I'm,
I'm fine with that.
But what I think ladies and gentlemen is that in looking at these subjects,
whether the chem trails or cunty behavior or if there's a lot of different
points of view on things,
but,
uh,
what I really liked about that mic west guy that we had on yesterday as he's not
mean about it,
you know,
he doesn't,
he's not creating enemies.
He's creating Tony Hawk,
man.
He created Tony Arc.
That's,
I mean,
that's awesome.
That was the coolest thing.
I right there.
I mean,
he had,
he owned part owned one of the most successful companies and video games ever.
I mean,
yeah,
that's a great company.
Well,
he's a bad motherfucker.
He's,
uh,
and you know,
it's,
it kind of bums me out.
I think he's just exceptional guy.
And it kind of bums me out that a lot of people thought he was a government
shill and they got mad at me for having him on and he's got a point of view
folks.
And that point of view may be right.
And you know,
there's parts of your point of view that may have merit,
but I think there's a lot of people out there that aren't willing to consider
the possibility that parts of their point of view or a little wacky,
you know?
And when a guy like that comes along,
like he's gotta be working for the government,
you know,
like I was saying about tower seven yet.
Yeah.
It looks like a controlled demolition.
He says it does too,
but I don't know shit about making a building.
I really don't.
I know Jack Shit,
I don't know a goddamn thing.
And to pretend that you do,
if you know as much as I do about it,
and to pretend like if I know for a fact that you don't have any more
information than I do about making buildings and you start arguing about Tarot
seven,
I'll call bullshit.
Because I know for me,
I've,
if we have the same amount of knowledge,
I don't know a fucking thing about how that fell.
I've no idea.
I would,
I would not know how you would control demolition one.
If you told me that they could control demolition of building,
where they would blow it up to bring it down.
I'd be like,
that's not how they do it.
I feel like if I didn't know that it existed,
if you brought it to,
he said,
listen,
I'm thinking about taking down this building.
What am I gonna do is I'm gonna set dynamite in it all throughout it and if I do
it correctly,
it's gonna explode and it'll all collapse.
I'd be like,
what a stupid fucking way.
Why don't you just chip away at it from the top to the bottom?
That's what I would say.
I would say,
why the fuck are you doing that?
What did those wrecking ball thing for?
Don't you use those?
Use that thing.
Don't blow it up,
but they blow them up all the time.
They blow it up.
It's like a standard thing.
So what the fuck do I know?
I,
I've looked at it and it looks like a controlled demolition,
but the reality is I,
and I have to face that head on.
I don't know shit about structural engineering like zero.
I know zero and people that do dough it,
you know that are architects and it's not their specialty.
They can be wrong about stuff.
One thing I
always wonder,
judge,
you always seem to always have a slight conspiracy with a lot of things and
it's,
you know,
over years a couple of those things faded away.
Like I,
you know,
first when you first heard the aids thing and you're like,
hey,
just doesn't exist.
I never said that.
What I said is these people say it doesn't,
right,
right.
I never believed it and I still don't believe it to this day.
But you're a diehard about it.
It's what I mean.
What I'm die hard about is the fact that I do think that there might be some
merit to some of what the,
not the aids deniers have said,
but the people that are saying that when they're measuring AIDS in Africa,
they're adding to this number of people that have contracted HIV and gotten
aids.
What I've been told is it,
a lot of those people actually didn't get measured for HIV.
They just have aids.
And so you're dealing with a host of different reasons why they could have
gotten aids.
It could be massive malnutrition.
And it doesn't mean there's not people that are getting HIV and getting aids
either.
It's not like they're mutually exclusive,
but it's like there's some,
uh,
some,
some weirdness probably with the numbers that you're,
they're linking it to this a sexually transmitted disease.
So when this guy is talking about this disease,
you know,
like a,
like a Peter Duesberg,
it's the guy,
a guy who doesn't believe that HIV causes AIDS.
The real problem is there's so many people that do,
and if there's a whole industry involved in medicine,
I mean it's,
it's,
it's not just a,
a bunch of doctors that are comparing notes.
There's a lot of money involved and there's a lot,
there's a lot of,
there's a lot of different universities that are teaching medicine that are
heavily invested in the future of medicine is constantly getting better.
It's like pretty measurable all the time.
So the idea that something like this would slip between the cracks and they
wouldn't realize that HIV doesn't really cause any,
it's just like,
I don't understand how that's even possible and I'm too stupid when it comes to
the,
the business of medicine or even the science of medicine.
I'm too ignorant to even engage in the conversation,
but it doesn't make sense to me that,
that many people,
even if it was like,
if it was some sort of a mistake that it had been made in the past,
I feel like it'd be impossible for them to keep that quiet.
But I don't know,
you know,
I don't know the moon thing.
The moon one is a big one.
Yeah,
that's a big one because,
um,
I got really roped in by this Fox special,
there's a Fox special called a conspirator,
think it was called conspiracy theory.
Did we go to the mood?
And it was awesome.
And,
um,
it was fox I guess wasn't leaning as conservative back then or something like
that.
It wasn't like Fox News.
Yes,
it was like Fox,
you know,
dramatic reality TV show ish.
And,
um,
it was a great fucking special.
It really got me,
they had an astronauts saying that they could have faked going to the moon
astronaut.
Yeah.
Brian O'leary.
We said that if it was possible that if they didn't get it or if the they
footage got destroyed,
that they would fake it.
And I remember hearing that going wide.
And then,
you know,
you start looking at documentaries that support the idea that we didn't go to
the moon.
It's very compelling.
There's a really good English one,
a,
I forgot the name of it.
They're very compelling.
But when you go online and then start reading the arguments against all their
arguments,
it's a pretty compelling that the wrong about a lot of shit.
Just a lot.
They're wrong about so much.
There's so many things that they say,
uh,
in the,
the ones where they're,
they're trying to say that we didn't go to the moon.
There's so many things that they say that don't make any sense.
The things that make sense or some of the photographs.
Um,
there's,
there's some images that look like really staged and not just a look really
stage,
but like the way their lit,
it's really odd.
But don't you think that would be something where there's so many people that
would have to be involved for that to actually,
yeah.
You know,
one person on their death bed would scream it and you would find it.
No,
it's true.
That's,
that's the major argument against it.
In fact,
the major,
major argument against it is human nature that people wouldn't be able to keep a
secret that long.
Right.
You know,
I've read that,
uh,
that Bill Clinton quote,
which is a fantastic quote
about the moon landing,
and it always freaks me out and it's,
it's such a conspiracy theorist,
wet dream of a post because,
you know,
Bill Clinton,
his fucking Bill Clinton,
you know,
he's a former president of the United States and he's writing a book about his
time in his life.
And in this book he writes about the experience of talking to an old carpenter
about the moon landings.
I mean it's a crazy quote because what he's essentially says,
I'll read it.
I was really high when I left that as fuck.
Thinking about blow jobs.
I mean Shit,
when we got to write a book here,
I fucking hate books.
I don't read what if that was like his writing partner?
Just did that.
Throw that in there.
Cause he was a big conspiracy theorist guy and then he GI bill just actually
never read that book.
Just fucked him.
Come on man.
You know I don't have time for raid.
What do I like?
I like head and cheeseburgers.
Okay.
Why ain't giving me books on,
have you had,
wait,
are you allowed to eat burgers anymore?
No,
I don't need cheeseburgers.
So you haven't even tried the Pretzel Burger from Wendy's?
No,
I'm not fucking with,
it's like the Baconator but they add pretzel.
It's great.
A Baconator with Pretzel.
Yeah.
It's just a mushy mess of pretzels and cheese and burn rights to try to kill
you.
Do you understand this?
They're trying to do,
that's not good.
That sounds terrible for you.
Yeah.
You don't care?
No,
no.
I don't know if I had it once.
I'm just saying it's great.
You just had it though.
I have made a decision this year to clean up various aspects of my life and a
big one being diet,
right?
Yeah.
Just the,
the,
the
constant eating of certain things that I know are not healthy and in a cutting
out gluten and it's such a fucking fatty thing that I hate even talking about
it.
Everyone's cutting out gluten.
It feels so gross when you tell people you're not eating gluten.
It's like,
Oh,
you bought into that.
It's like you,
you immediately get roped into this,
this fad category and that's not what I'm saying at all.
I'm saying I don't think it's good for you.
I don't think it's a fad.
I think in,
in,
in me eating gluten,
I was doing my body damage.
Like in no uncertain terms.
Yeah.
I mean it is kind of fatty to like,
yeah,
I'm pretty much gluten free.
Dairy,
dairy man.
Yeah.
There is not good for you.
You know,
like you always talk about that raw milk and shit.
I'm like,
I am.
I hate milk.
I hate,
I have zero calcium in my body.
If I fall down,
I'm like ms Mr. Burns.
Yeah,
I think,
um,
you're better off with nothing with no milk,
but if you're going to have milk,
raw milk is not bad on occasion.
I just think,
uh,
we,
we take in a lot of dairy and it is a weird thing for our bodies,
but some people can process it without a problem,
you know?
And some people have real issues with it.
It,
we're not supposed to fuck with cows.
Maybe the Indians are right.
Maybe,
but when you drink it,
I'm telling you,
man,
if you drink it raw,
you don't really have nearly as many problems to adjusting it.
Like a lot of people who are lactose intolerant or only lactose intolerant when
it's her modernizer pasteurized.
I shouldn't say a lot of people,
but certain people,
what have I counted?
I had done a census.
No,
just talking mad shit.
Um,
this is the,
uh,
this is the Bill Clinton quote because it's so crazy.
This is right out of his book.
He says,
just just a month before Apollo 11 astronauts buzz Aldrin and Neil Armstrong,
I left their colleague,
Michael Collins,
a board spaceship,
Colombian walked on the moon beating by five months.
President Kennedy's goal of putting a man on the moon before the decade,
right was out.
The old cop and asked me if I really believed it happened.
I said,
sure.
I saw it on television.
He disagreed.
He said that he didn't believe anything.
He didn't believe it for a minute and that them television fillers could make
things look real that weren't back then.
I thought he was a crank during my eight years in Washington.
I saw some things on TV that made me wonder if it wasn't ahead of his time.
That's a cookie quote.
Okay.
It is a cookie quote,
no matter how you slice it.
Has anyone asked him about that quote?
Um,
like did we just did,
oh,
we just,
we just heard Mr President,
please turn it on.
Right on the record though.
Like,
I mean that seems like such a powerful quote that somebody somewhere had to,
it filmed him like,
hey,
can I ask you one question about this?
I don't think people want to fuck with the moon landings.
Um,
my friend,
uh,
Todd Mccormick has the best quote about it.
He said it's a technological Jesus.
He said,
cause if it really did pull it off and you know,
it really,
they really,
it actually fake going to the moon.
Like oh my God,
what an incredible in horrific embarrassment.
And if they did go to the moon and your talking about it and you're like,
you know,
pretending that they didn't,
you're a crazy person.
Like if they actually went to the,
and these guys really did rest of their lives and go 250,000 miles and land on
the moon and then come back for the first time ever that people had been
actually in deep space and back and in and lived and touched and land on an
object and came back from that object first time ever.
I mean you would be such a douchebag if you were saying that they didn't do it
and they did do it.
I 100% of the thing.
We went to the man.
It's most likely that we did.
Most likely I still leave open the possibility that some of that was horse shit
just because Dan was just how they rocked it back then and there's also,
there's a,
the guy who was a Jesus Christ,
what does his fucking name,
there's the safety inspector tunnel,
Thomas Ronald Baron.
He was hired by,
by Congress to do a detailed safety analysis of NASA and he handed in this long
report that said that NASA was in such disarray that they would never get a man
into space.
He died on the train tracks,
parked in a car with his family shortly thereafter and the report went bye bye
and that's real.
There's weird shit to the moon landings.
Not like one weird thing,
but a bunch of weird things.
There's weird things to it.
It's a most likely that we definitely went,
but it's also possible that there's some fuckery going on because they did a
little fuckery back then with publicity photos that Gemini 15 photo is one of
them that shows Michael Collins floating in space and they said he was on a
space walk,
but then it's the exact same photo just reversed of him in a training facility.
It's a famous photo.
Yeah,
but it's a publicity photo.
Exactly.
But Bliss,
that's what it's,
you know,
I mean that if I give you a photo of like,
hey,
you need Joe Rogan,
like crazy publicity photo for his show and I had a lens flare to your,
your balls.
If they're going to be like,
wait a second,
let's Linds players.
That's a good point.
If it was a publicity photo,
if it wasn't actually released as a,
an actual factual photo of space,
I think it kind of was,
but that could also,
that's not even indicative of the whole company being full of Shit.
It could be just one photographic editor.
There's just thinks he's slick and he's like,
look,
I'll just put this guy in space.
Right.
You know,
it doesn't mean that NASA is full of Shit,
it's just,
but when people see things like that they go,
Oh okay well I'm going to be suspicious he now cause you're not in totally on
the up and up.
You know there's,
there's certain aspects of,
of the story that make you go,
oh okay well there's something,
some,
there's some
fuckery at some levels and it's unfortunate that you can,
you can get that from a single picture that's been edited but you can,
you know,
you could do it raises the possibilities.
So most likely,
yeah they went,
most likely they went.
But I always leave in that one one possible opening for a crazy scenario where
they faked the whole thing and got Stanley Kubrick behind it and spent billions
of dollars of black budget money and filmed it and then told the astronauts,
listen bitch,
you're,
no one's going to believe you.
You're a national hero.
You went to the moon,
just deal with it.
I mean that to me is so compelling as well.
Cause it almost would explain how crazy we are.
I would almost explain like the,
the difference between the the United States of the future that we saw and like
the 1970s on television and when it really became,
as far as like space travel,
space travel just stopped.
It just stopped.
It's like we don't even do the shuttle really anymore.
I mean we,
we have to like borrow the Russians to go up to the space station.
We're like,
we just stopped and people say,
well it's because of lack of funding and that is absolutely true.
That's absolutely the case.
But it's still weird.
It's still weird that between 1969 in 1972 we flew out and landed on the moon
and came back and we did it a bunch of times and then we're like,
we're done.
That's it.
Done.
Now we just go 300 miles and that's it.
No higher than that.
400 miles Max.
Like people don't go above 400 miles.
Like the last time people have been above 400 miles is the Paulsboro space
programs.
So again,
most likely.
Yeah,
most likely they went to the moon for sure.
But I,
I am the Dork in me.
The,
the conspiracy loon that's still alive and the corner of the back of my brain
holding onto an ember and blowing on it every now and then,
trying to keep the fire of madness alive,
still wants to believe that they could affect it.
We just need to get Neil degrasse Tyson back in there too.
I love that guy so much.
I'm such a fan.
If to me they'd be like arguing with
Paul Mccartney or about whether it was his music is good.
Yeah.
And I'm not an argument about it any man,
but that's so bullshit.
So contradictory because I do argue about it,
but what I mean about it is I'm,
I'm really not committed.
It sounds,
that sounds like bullshit to that.
I'm not committed to one side or the other.
I'm being totally honest.
Most likely they went to the moon most likely like 99% but the honest childlike
idiot in me,
the child like idiot who loves mysteries,
we'll fucking hold out for that bitch.
You really need to write a movie man about like the faking the moon landing and
make it ridiculous,
like big foot's in there with a werewolf and one of those cool Scifi movies
like,
uh,
like Sharknado,
oh my God,
the Werewolf going on in space.
What do you think it is?
Why do people want to believe that there are grand conspiracies?
That there's these,
you know,
people
love to talk about grand conspiracies that may or may not exist,
but they invest a lot of time and a lot of effort into these fucking things.
I think it's just like the same people that do that with Jesus and God and
religion and stuff like that,
that if you take that out,
like,
Hey,
I'm not religious,
but I need to obsess and find secrets of other things that don't exist.
Is that it?
You know,
there's,
there's a searching for something and the answer,
yeah.
There's a lot of people that believe that that's like a genetic thing.
They're like,
there's a gene for like religious belief that it's actually a part of a,
you know,
a part of who we are as human beings.
I mean,
I grew up religious by force and my mom's super religious,
but when I don't have to go,
I'm not even thinking about it,
you know?
But I don't,
if I had to go back and do it once in a while,
I have no problem with that.
It's kind of relaxing.
It's like being in a,
you know,
a tanning bed.
It's kind of like a place where everybody is guaranteed to be chill,
but it's going to be all about Jesus.
They're all going to be God likes or they're going to be real pleasant with each
other.
Like there's a lot of benefits to having a church,
that atheist kind of a shoe,
you know,
throw aside.
And in a lot of ways the right,
because it's like,
okay,
we're going to get those benefits.
But in return you're going to give up your personal freedom if freedom of
behavior,
your freedom of,
uh,
you know,
have to love and marry who you want.
You didn't give a blot of shit.
But in return you get a nice place to go on Sunday where everybody's going to be
nice and they're going to us all sing stupid ass songs together and they're
going to be showered and it's like an excuse to dress up nice once in a woman
dressed up nice and,
uh,
try to reinforce the good behavior habits of the community.
I mean there's Ben,
there's merit in that and it's unfortunate that it has to be done for a lot of
folks through an invisible deity.
But you know,
they would probably argue the smarter ones amongst them.
That spirituality in itself is trying to,
you know,
it's like a cop out to say you don't believe in God,
but you know,
you believe in a higher power.
Like what,
what exactly is that higher power Ni?
I mean,
what definition do you have of God that's so bulletproof as written by the
Bible.
You,
if you're,
say you believe in a higher power,
but you know,
you're,
you're more spiritual than religious.
Like what,
what are you even saying?
Like what a,
what exactly are you saying?
Have you been in church for a while?
Like,
I haven't been for a while and I'm thinking maybe there'd be cool things to do.
Like get it,
bring a laser pointers that when you see one of those kids playing with the toys
and you can just like fuck with the kid the whole time.
That might be fine.
Dad's NYSID
churches,
not for games.
You've missed the whole point of church.
It's for worship now.
I've never been,
you know,
a,
I haven't been since I was a little kid.
I mean,
but I know people who like it,
man,
they really like it.
They're nice people.
They liked going to church and you know,
if you have your idea of what it means to be God,
what it means to be Jesus,
you know,
and if you have your idea and that idea empowers you,
there's a benefit in that.
And atheists don't want to
admit to that.
They think the people should be able to get by without it.
And they should.
You're right.
But the way to help them is not by belittling them.
It's more of biolog explaining to them,
you know,
if possible,
if they're open to it,
explaining to them exactly what religion is.
Because it's not that you're against God.
This has nothing to do with God.
It has nothing to do with even the idea of God.
It's entirely based on people writing shit down and just because people are
saying that they represent God,
that you to listen to that.
It's just like listening to people that are telling you that they're from
another planet or telling you that they're psychic there.
You're just,
you're,
you have to trust these crazy people.
You have to trust these people.
And that's,
that's the real problem with religion.
It's human beings.
It's not that the idea that there's a god man who not world so fucking crazy.
There could be a gun.
It really could be.
The world is so nuts,
man.
It's so,
so much of it does,
it doesn't even seem real so much of the Syria thing and you're going about the
radiation leaking from Japan.
I mean every day it's like a,
of a bigger indication that this whole thing is just fucking bananas.
And no one knows how to keep the lid on it.
And there's billions of gallons of radioactive water leaking into the ocean and
they're killing people in Syria.
And we're going to go kill people for killing people.
And whew,
God damn,
I mean it,
it feels,
it feels about as crazy and fake is.
It could be.
And I don't know how having a god would make it feel any less vague if a god
created all of us in this very disappointed in us.
Now that's not any less likely than a lot of things that are actually real.
You know?
And I'm not saying that I believe in God,
not saying that either.
I'm just saying how could,
how could you even know?
How could you know what the fuck is next?
How could you even have a guess?
I guess you could have possibilities as you know,
things he bounced around in your imagination,
especially if you've had psychedelic experiences.
You can have some possibilities.
But how the fuck do you know?
You don't know.
And to say you do is almost as bad as is.
It's almost as bad to pretend that you know there's no god is it is to pretend
that you're talking to God.
Right?
And yes,
even paying attention
of course of year tried to have a conversation with an adult.
No,
I mean I always think you see the problem with being stone is that you start
talking about something and an idea and then while I'm just going off,
that's interesting right there and start thinking about that one idea you're
still going on with,
you know what I mean?
You like slowed down the weeds slowed you down.
So that's right.
I started thinking about going off about something about God being simulation
theory.
I was thinking of simulation.
Did some cigarettes,
man,
that cigarettes fucking with you.
Fuck with your mind.
Hey,
did you read that thing about I'm gaining weight.
Um,
there was a in today about it had to do with cigarettes that they've found a
reason why people gain weight after they quit cigarettes.
And it has to do with the changing of the,
uh,
stomach flora,
which really interesting stuff.
I thought it was just because it made your heart go faster,
so on and off more coherently.
Not apparently not.
I got to find this thing and you crave putting things in your mouth,
you know,
I don't want to know about all that.
Okay.
You crave and shit in your mouth.
Ooh,
I'm trying to find this.
Um,
I,
there has to be a link to cigarettes and breastfeeding and breastfeeding.
Yeah.
Something about breastfeeding too much maybe or breastfeeding too little and
then the whole cigarette thing is also just putting something in your mouth all
the time for you for it.
No,
that's what I mean.
Like when you quit smoking,
you people buy suckers or candy or gum cause you're constantly trying to do
something with your mouth.
Really.
Yeah.
It's like a oral fixation type thing.
Disco Sucks.
Some Cox,
you know,
you want to,
yeah,
whatever.
Cigarettes.
Hold on.
Typing this into Google.
I can't find it.
I know I retweeted it.
Sometimes a Twitter doesn't retweet things.
The you ask it to you?
No,
no sir.
Um,
usually if,
what probably happens is that somebody who may be deleted the tweet and then re
like changed like a spelling error or re posted it.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
Here it goes.
A scientist's link,
weight gain from quitting smoking to a shift in gut bacteria correlated with
obesity.
That is amazing.
You know,
they're finding out more and more that stomach flora and it has a massive impact
on your mood,
your behavior,
your immune system,
all sorts of different shit as affected by the,
uh,
amount of bacteria that it literally can change your behavior.
And so how do you protect it?
Is He using like those milk or yogurt shots?
Is that the same time?
Yeah,
those will help you.
Those are our healthy bacteria.
That's a,
those are probiotic.
Sauerkraut is very probiotic too for people who don't like 'em raw sauerkraut,
especially Kimchi is very probiotic.
I love Kimchi.
That's stuff's delicious.
I love Sauerkraut.
You can eat if you eat.
Yeah.
Make sure it's the right time of a lot.
That's probiotic.
Find out like,
do a little Google search on what's the best probiotic.
Um,
uh,
Sauerkraut,
I think a lot of natural sauerkraut is naturally probiotic because it's sort of
fermenting and growing bacteria in it.
Um,
and uh,
Kombucha,
that's what I like.
But acid office is a big ones from no culture.
Acid office is a good one too because it's very aggressive like a,
they say that acidophilus is good in preventing certain sicknesses because
it'll,
it's a flora that like stays on your skin and if it's,
if
it's healthy,
if you have a lot of it,
it's sorta deters the infection by other things that you might touch.
But that could be harsh it since I'm not a doctor,
but I thought you would think this is pretty interesting.
So cause I know you had complained that that was a problem.
Like when you'd quit smoking then it would be like a real problem with um,
with four or holding your weight.
Yeah,
it's whole,
it's just,
cause I mean when you smoke cigarettes,
you don't have a,
you don't really think of food as much.
Like it creates,
takes your cravings of food away.
Somebody needs to hire Joey Diaz to do when those blu cigarette commercials,
because he smokes those things all day.
Now I go,
what are you doing?
I go,
are you smoking cigarettes again?
Same cigarette dogs is nothing.
Barely comes out.
It's like a little mess.
There's nothing coming out of there.
I'm like,
you're smoking cigarettes
and he's watching spongebob squarepants which is hilarious because I remember
the day at Cobb's in San Francisco.
He goes,
I was talking about a South Park.
Yep.
You're fucking cartoons.
You watching cartoons.
He starts going on this rampage about how you watched it for his ultimate bait.
I know,
but he loves it now.
Love Spongebob.
Squarepants this is like his favorite.
That's hilarious.
He was so fucking funny this weekend.
Oh my God,
I'm going to Waukee.
Yeah.
He's so funny.
He's like,
he's in his prime right now.
You know?
He's like,
he's in this rare era.
He's got this fucking Liberace joke.
It's one of my favorite jokes that he's ever done and it's like,
it's getting better every time you see it.
Like he keeps adding to it and fixing it and tweaking it.
He's killing them out there.
So fun dude.
He's working it and that dude's he works.
Oh,
he definitely works.
He puts it a lot of work.
But it's also,
he's,
he's getting better too.
It's really fun.
I just love people that still love stand up.
You know.
Joey fucking loves it.
He loves it.
He really,
really enjoys it.
You know,
like he has no problem like hanging out with people and,
and uh,
talking to people after the shows.
He really enjoys it.
Hey,
did you a I put this on Twitter.
That's another interesting story.
Um,
it's that men experience a blow to their self esteem when their female partners
experienced success,
even when they aren't in direct competition.
Isn't that crazy?
Women's success also negatively impacts how men view the future of the
relationship.
Researchers found.
That's incredible.
First of all,
researchers researching,
I'm,
we're researching breakups.
Wait,
wait.
So you're,
what you're saying is if they're more successful,
that scares the person.
It's apparently that's exactly what they're saying.
I think it's implying is that a man wants a woman to be weak.
And if the woman proves that she is successful,
that she can be independent of the man,
that it's very threatening.
I Dunno,
because I can think of it both ways.
Like,
cause I know a girl that so many girls that don't have jobs,
you know,
and it's just like,
God,
you got to do something.
What are you doing?
Living off welfare,
sleeping on people's couches.
I mean like,
that is the biggest challenge.
Do you know like that?
Like 50,
60 just kidding.
But no,
I few girls,
but I mean,
and trying to go anywhere like relationship wise with them,
that was a huge turnoff because it's like,
come on,
what am I going to take care of this person for the rest of my life?
You know,
like what am I saying my daddy?
Is that what I'm going to be Daddy?
Yeah.
Well,
it's also,
you're dating girls that are much younger,
18,
19,
but yeah,
their children,
they just escape from their home and they're abusive home.
Um,
I met a girl recently that I say this,
uh,
I met a girl recently
think that was older than her mom.
Oh Christ.
That's so gross.
You silly bitch.
It's weird.
I kind of can see how for a lot of men that are insecure,
that would be like a real thing.
It's fucking hard to be secure with like a,
a really powerful woman in a relationship.
Can you imagine if you were like dating Jennifer Lopez and she's like a,
what are you doing today?
And you're like,
oh,
I'm going to go to do a podcast.
And she's like,
Oh really?
Well I'm hosting the Grammy's.
Yeah.
And your puts on some diamonds.
Wiggles her ass in of funny and walks out the door and took a bunch of dudes
hold up the door for her and she slides into a limousine,
photographers snap a picture and then she darts off and like,
damn,
that bitch doesn't need me at all.
She doesn't even need me a little.
Yeah.
But if you were both famous like that,
I think it would work or like at least made enough to a point where you're just
like,
all right,
we're both chill with our,
you know,
we're both making good money to get,
maybe.
Yeah.
But maybe they compete against each other like superstars,
you know,
maybe Catherine Zeta Jones and Michael Douglas,
maybe that was part of the Duke was like how good he played Liberace.
God Damn,
no,
they actually fucked like him and Matt Damon Probably.
Well,
he's like,
I got to do it.
It's for the park.
That's why,
um,
the,
uh,
the study,
I thought it was fascinating.
They,
that they did a study on this,
but it also thought it was fascinating the results because they kind of make
sense.
I've known,
especially like for a week,
man,
you know,
it's,
I think it's probably really hard for a lot of dudes who are not like where they
want to be to deal with.
Like,
uh,
like a partner who's like maybe possibly surpassing them,
you know,
and like they're the social ladder or the perceived success ladder,
like passing them.
And like almost making them feel diminished by their own woman.
Like in competition,
like you,
you've met guys that like you can't play basketball with them because if they
lose they get,
they get shitty.
Have you ever met people like that or pool or,
or a video game?
Yeah,
but I've also known [inaudible] ex girlfriends and women that I've known that
got mad or jealous of like my position in my job.
Like,
Oh,
you have to just get paid to talk all day.
But I have a black,
like I think it works.
I think it works both ways.
That's just,
again,
the people,
you're fucking hanging around with sun.
I have to put shit in my ass all day.
And when you have to talk price.
Yeah.
But you know that talking
thing is something that you kind of like figured out how to get there.
All right.
And if she wants to talk for a living,
she needs to figure out how to get there.
It's really that simple.
I mean,
just because you did doesn't mean that she can't.
And it also doesn't mean that somehow or another you took anything away from
her.
So when people are like Shitty to you about your thing that you're doing,
like you're,
you,
you're missing out on a huge opportunity to be bored with your own life and do
something about it.
Like to bitch about Ya.
You don't have to do anything.
I ain't doing it.
They're talking,
hey,
yeah,
you didn't even work.
I ain't seen Tak.
Ah,
you ever done a hurricane's mark in your life?
Next time.
Yes,
I've done about 20 years will get mad at you if you don't work hard.
Yeah.
Look at you with your manicured fingers.
You know,
if it's struggling,
you don't even hate,
you didn't even hate work and life,
right?
Yeah.
Folks,
it ain't about that.
It ain't about the guy who tries buying a clean car when you're dirty.
It's not his fault.
It's,
you should figure out how to be clean.
You should figure out how to do a job that doesn't involve you walking in mud
all day.
And that's possible because somebody else has done it.
And it doesn't mean I don't buy the idea that you know the society the way it is
right now.
It has to be this way.
Someone's always going to have to work at Burger King.
Someone's always going to have to,
I don't buy that.
I think people are pretty fucking flexible.
If you look at the broad spectrum of humans and human behavior from different
cultures all over the world,
it's a pretty obvious to me that there's,
there's a lot of different ways that people can act.
We don't have to have fast food workers.
We don't,
we don't have to have people who work shit jobs.
We don't have to,
which you need to figure out how to restructure society.
So everybody somehow or another plays a part,
has something to contribute,
something to share.
I mean,
that's what a real society is supposed to be like.
I've given you some coconuts,
you give me some fish,
you know,
we make a deal and you'd do it back and forth and left and right.
And when there's nothing to contribute,
then you start looking.
Lit President needs to give us jobs.
We need jobs.
So instead of something to contribute,
just find something to do with your time and then it becomes about doing that
more than it becomes about finding something to contribute.
So society gets wrapped around becoming a part of a machine society instead of
becoming a bunch of individuals that are expressing themselves and unique ways
and everybody's sort of borrows and shares and sells this and you sell that.
And we all sort of figured out how we can contribute in a society.
We got sidetracked and diverted into these boxes that they call companies and
corporations and we got stuck into these containers that go cubicles or offices
and we've got forced into this system.
So our time,
instead of it being invested in making pottery or,
or fixing cars or doing something where you have a passion or you have some sort
of a connection to,
instead of that you've sold your life to sit in a box and work for a machine,
an uncaring machine that demands productivity.
It doesn't understand you,
it doesn't want to understand you.
It has a bunch of very strict things in order to keep the humor at a minimum in
the office.
Just in case one,
he fuckheads says some stupid sex jokes that gets him sued and they have to give
somebody $1 million.
So get it together.
And this is your life now.
No natural behavior.
Everybody's wearing clothes they don't want to,
where everybody's showing up and doing something they don't want to do and they
have no connection to.
That's the problem with our society.
And then what's the reward for all this stuff?
Go home,
get a big TV,
go home.
You're going to get a shiny belt buckle.
You're going to get a nice purse.
You're going to wear shoes that you couldn't afford last week.
You're going to get that dream car.
And every week we're chasing down this new object and every week we're trying to
fill this hole in this,
this,
this sad shadow of a life that we've been left with after work that you work
eight to whatever,
the hours a day plus commuting and then you'll like this
and that's your life.
That's your real fucking life.
All that other stuff is not your life anymore.
All that other stuff is work.
And most of us have committed to that.
I know you've been there before and I've been there before and we,
we understand that it's a trap because we got out of it,
but for the people that are in it,
a lot of times they don't even understand it's a trap.
They just think it's a good job.
I think they got dental.
I'm doing really good.
I got my own parking spots,
got my name on it,
and you just,
a piece of a heartless shitty machine that makes money.
Okay.
The Joe Rogan experience,
I could just see like being cut into one of those youtube videos.
That's somebody who isn't in the background.
There's like people walking fast,
then the sun rising really slow and we'll,
you know what,
man?
Somebody got to say that because if people don't hear it,
they're going to get a bad job and they're gonna,
they're gonna waste their fucking life.
Right,
but don't you think you'd have to go through all that just to figure out what
you want to do?
Because I didn't think I did,
but I don't think you have to look.
I,
I did,
but I became,
when I became a comedian,
when I was 21 I was 100% convinced that I was going to be a standup comedian for
the rest of my life.
Like I didn't need to worry about what was next.
I was like,
oh,
this is what I'm doing.
Like I'm this,
no,
I don't want to do anything else like this.
This is what I'm doing.
Once I found it,
I was good.
All the jobs were just to feed myself while I was trying to make that work.
But it's,
um,
to get one and commit to it and have it become a part of your life becomes
really problematic because if you're,
if you are a dirt bag like myself who drove limos and did construction and they
always,
you know,
almost kind of temporary jobs and a lot of people drift in and out of,
there was nothing expected of you.
But if you get hired by a major corporation and become a big part of their,
their,
you know,
their program.
Like let's say you're also an animator and you get a Gig.
Like I have a friend who,
uh,
was,
an illustrator and he was working for Nickelodeon and he got fired and he was
panicking and he was like,
shit,
I don't know what the fuck to do.
He's like,
ah,
you know,
I gotta I gotta figure out another job.
So he started making paintings and selling his paintings.
It was the greatest thing that's ever happened to him.
Now he's a soup.
His name's Todd white.
He's just super successful artists.
He makes like this,
uh,
kind of Martini style cocktail was from the,
like,
like cocktail parties from the 1920s,
like those cool kind of cartoonish Martini glass things.
He's got a real specific,
distinctive style.
It's really cool.
He's a great artist and he's also a black belt in Jujitsu.
I know him from a John Joc Machado's.
He's a great guy,
but it was,
uh,
an opportunity for him to,
to lose a job and even a job that he loved as an illustrator.
But,
you know,
I'm sure he'd much rather do what he wants to do and do what's going on in his
mind and that's close to him.
Oh,
he's really cool.
He's bad ass and he's a great guy too.
Very cool guy.
Very.
He's a talented Jujitsu guy too.
Last time I rode with him,
he catch me in a number.
Let me like this.
Yeah,
he's very good.
All of this stuff is really cool.
It's,
it's,
uh,
it's very uniquely him.
Do you ever go to like art galleries and he just have some wine and check out an
art?
Never do any of that stuff.
I'm losing patients with humans.
No,
I can't.
I have been our calories.
Sure.
Yeah.
There's,
um,
you know,
the,
I liked certain types of art.
I'm really into like sculptures I really liked.
Yeah.
I'm fascinated by that.
Fascinating.
Really good sculptures and really good painting.
But I went to this art gallery that had like a lot of this like really?
Um,
what's the way you would put it?
I guess it's modern sort of abstract,
that Jackson Pollock type stuff and it was so ridiculously expensive.
It was like it was,
it was hurting my feelings.
I was,
I was looking at these paintings like this is just some paint.
This is just,
you threw some paint around and now you want a shitload of money for this thing.
Like this is crazy.
I can't get into that.
I can't,
I just can't.
I get it.
I get this,
Maybe like it would make a room look brighter.
Stick that in the corner.
I don't get it being worth $30,000.
I don't get that.
This doesn't make any sense to me.
I see what that is.
That's some paint that I could take my four year old and I could get her to do
that.
Yeah,
I don't,
I buy prints.
I believe in prints.
Like there's like this whole thing where people look down on prince like,
Oh,
you're just printed it out.
But you know,
there's only whatever.
But,
uh,
I,
I love art and I just start recently got into it,
but I noticed that when looking at my walls,
I have a theme of like boobs and like course sexy women and stuff like that.
My uncle,
I don't know if I ever told,
he's my uncle growing up,
my aunt and uncle,
we'd go to his house for Christmas and there would be these crazy humongous
paintings off.
Like they have a nice farm house,
really old school,
like family
and then they would have these humongous paintings.
I've just naked people or women naked women everywhere,
like,
Eh,
like discuss and they would have penthouses in the,
in the bathroom.
Oh yeah.
You told me about this family.
Yeah.
But it's like I'm turning into that.
That's so weird because you don't have kids.
Yeah.
If you have kids come over and that's how you're living or that's,
that's where it gets different.
You know,
you saw that when you were a kid,
right?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
And I would sit there and take like 15 poops.
No.
Well,
no,
no kid.
Yeah.
That's the deal.
It if they don't have kids.
So totally different environment.
Yeah.
It's like they actually live like natural people.
People have kids up to hide everything.
So you're living like an actual man.
It's what like if men wanted to decorate their house and they didn't worry about
the repercussions of the design,
there'd be tits everywhere.
They're the only reason we're going to have tits all over our house is because
women would get mad at us.
But if you went over a guy's house and saw tits everywhere,
you're like,
oh,
this guy is not going to stick with these not marrying me.
This is not going to work out.
We're not having a family together.
He's going to stick it in me.
And then another girl,
and then he looked like this black tits over here and Chinese tits over there.
Like nobody wants that in the female kingdom.
They don't want that.
They'll start taking them down if they move in with you.
The first thing that's going as the tetes,
we got to take those tits down and was just too much.
We can replace them with my tests.
Like,
maybe you'll get that.
I always had that problem whenever I lived with a girl where you're like,
look,
we have to take down this poster of Terminator.
Oh,
we're putting up a basket and putting some,
and there's a lot of men who won't admit that they're changing because the woman
wants them to behave differently.
And those guys become a real problem because they,
they start to justify their behavior is if it's correct,
they'll say things to you like,
you know,
why don't you just grow up,
man?
Like,
seriously?
I think it's about time.
You take the tits down off your wall.
I mean,
fuck bro,
you're almost 40 all right.
Really?
Meanwhile,
they're miserable and you're smoking pot giggling,
watching Scifi films while they were arguing with your wife and your walls are
covered with tits.
So no one's wrong here.
Okay,
I hope you like your life.
And I,
you know,
and,
and what,
but you can't be,
you can't tell someone that the way they're living with tits on their wall is a
bad way.
It's not.
It's just not your way.
But everybody doesn't want,
they don't want options.
They don't want you to have that option without being a loser.
No,
no,
no.
You,
you're losing and I'm winning.
Do you understand you with your tits on your wall,
you're almost fucking 40.
Pull your pants up.
Loser.
You're,
they want you to be a loser.
This one girl that I know,
I went to her house and she noted she was in the industry and the industry.
I love it how you said that.
She has a lot,
to me that's a movie.
Yeah.
Which was important,
but she had this lot of artists,
friends that like,
you know,
she was in like comic books and stuff like that where they're drawing,
but she would have all these fans sent her,
send her like pictures of herself,
like these humongous paintings.
I've like her bending over like her butthole and it's like a humongous,
and she's like,
I don't know,
I'm not
going to hang this up in my enough.
And so,
so she's like,
do you want this?
And part of me was like,
this would be the coolest thing in the whole entire road.
I would put this,
you know,
like then I'm like,
wait,
no,
I can't have a yes,
she could be shit.
If somebody I know bent over shit.
Got It.
And should have put it right behind you while the show's plan.
That would have been awesome.
How big is it?
Humongous.
Can you still get it?
No.
If you stream would mind if we put a bandaid over the buddle a that'd be off.
Just left it alone and just put a bad out over the butthole.
I should ask her.
That would be hilarious.
I had our show would probably lose a lot of credibility and some guests
wouldn't want to be on like a back when we had the flashlight as a sponsor.
Yeah.
There's a lot of guests that were like,
you know,
we can't be associated with the flashlight.
Do you still have a box of those or did they oh yeah.
You have to throw them out.
No,
no,
I'm good.
I've got them.
Do you want one?
Yeah,
I need a couple of things.
I think I have two or three lefts.
I keep coming over my house and stealing them.
I just want a fresh one day I was going.
I definitely have,
yeah,
I definitely have some I,
they sent me boxes of those things.
It's a,
it's a fascinating thing how people would negative,
like they would have a negative feeling about the show because of that and the,
one of the good things about having that as a sponsor is because no one can ever
take you seriously.
You didn't have any of the,
the responsibilities of someone who's like a serious journalist or if you're
being sponsored by the flashlight,
you're immediately dismissed.
So it's good.
It's good that way.
And anybody who comes on,
look,
you've got to realize you're being sponsored by the flashlight.
Didn't Sam Harris have a problem with that?
Do we do like no sponsors on his podcast?
I think that's how we worked around.
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah.
I think he was.
Well,
I mean it makes sense.
If the guy's like a serious intellectual,
I think it's going to come hang out with us assholes,
toxify rubber pussies and all kinds of craziness.
Yeah.
Imagine having Ashley Madison as a sponsor.
That would be weird Karma right there.
Yeah.
That seems like
if people want to go out and put together an illicit affair,
they don't need help.
You don't need a website,
but you know I ain't hating.
That's a Ashley Madison is an interesting one though.
It's like it shows the changing of the times and you can imagine if there were
anything like this existed in the 1980s or the 1990s it's like people are just
like opening up to so many weird and interesting new possibilities for how we
interact with each other.
I think that it's going to get real weird within the next 20 years.
Man.
Real fucking weird.
I think men and women are probably going to be able to do a lot of really weird
communication through a technology where you're going to have to,
you know,
have something that records either records experiences or can convey experiences
and you'd be able to sync up with each other.
You'd be able to feel what it feels like when you go inside of her.
It's probably going to have something to do with like almost a good the next
after Google glasses when they finally get it inside your eyeball.
You know?
And so you're,
it's,
it's reading your,
your thoughts and feelings.
If you have a relationship,
you're like,
all right,
I'm granting you access into my face.
You know what I mean?
Like so she can feel and see everything you did that it's almost gonna be,
that's gonna be the new marriage where like,
no,
I could to know exactly what's going on cause I could actually write you,
I'm on your database,
you know what I mean?
It's like,
does that make sense?
Totally makes sense.
And you could ask,
they could ask you if you want to pair,
you know,
should you allow Lydia to pair with you?
Right.
And you're like,
oh,
okay,
yes.
Yeah.
And then permanently it's like,
that's an option prominently like you have to throw your database away if you
want to get out of it or something like that.
I go to the apple store and they fucking do surgery on your head and you have to
grant certain acts as like if there's whatever the doctor is now,
right.
You'd have to grant like you get access to me,
to my body for the,
you know,
to fix me.
Yeah.
And then some rogue doctor,
you know,
is it not going to take the access away or is it,
we're going to hack it thinking to happen.
Tap in,
you're fucking dumb son.
And then the government's gonna find a way to get into your database and be able
to control you.
So where it's actually,
you're walking around,
well,
what's incredible is how close,
at least in concept it is to the Matrix,
the movie,
the Matrix.
When the dude had the big bolt in the back of his head,
then he realized when he got unplugged that he had been locked up to that thing.
That's,
I mean,
that idea is not farfetched.
Right?
It's just,
it's not,
it's they're going to be able to stimulate various aspects of the brain and
create memories.
They're going to be able to introduce artificial memories that haven't been
there before.
These are all like ideas.
They're pretty sure they're gonna be able to pull off
demolition,
man.
You've seen the demolition man,
right?
That's all mood.
No,
I mean this the loan,
right?
Yeah.
This is the and Wesley Snipes,
right?
The sexting.
This is a sex scene.
Yeah,
but in the future,
oh,
they were on opposite ends of the house or something like that.
I can't,
can't remember.
I think it's
what happens here.
They put helmets on ballots on.
Yeah,
that's right.
Oh,
this is hilarious.
What year was this?
I would say something like 95 or something like that.
We'll begin.
Woody says,
she says having sex of course,
like he doesn't.
He's like,
what the hell?
I don't even know about all this shit.
Three.
Is that Sandra Bullock?
Yeah,
of course.
Damn.
She's hot back then.
Still.
Oh.
Believe this.
Can't believe with meeting in the middle of the universe.
I have a little sex.
Wow.
Yeah.
Where the Blue Day?
I think he's just not in an expanse.
Oh,
so this is,
that's not how sex
other options.
That would be a nightmare.
That's not sexy.
Whoa.
This is crazy.
Nestle this,
dig it up.
I'm coming too hard.
Too fast.
What'd he say?
She goes,
is that what you call this?
Yeah.
That's what's been proven to produce higher orders of Alpha wave strain,
digitize transparency,
your sexual energies and obviously,
what do you say?
We just do it the old fashioned way.
Wow.
That sounds like a really well written movies.
That's back when they hadn't figured that out yet.
There's so many people that are just in love with that movie
Dog Shit about my movie just because the one weird,
sexy.
We're Sandra Bullock band man ever since she got in a new movie with helper.
No,
she said it's bill burn.
The migrant built and breaking bad.
I heard he isn't too.
That's bad ass Gilbert rules.
Do you watch that show?
No,
I do not.
I watched it the first season [inaudible] way back in the day.
Yeah,
but I haven't watched in a while.
It's one of those I got to catch up on it.
Especially now that this is the last season.
I'm just gonna Watch the whole thing.
Positive pregnancy tests in high demand on craigslist.
Man.
Chaz Bono is actually looking like a dude nowadays.
Yeah.
That's what happens man.
I think of that.
They pump you full of testosterone.
You lift weights for a few years.
What is the left that's all chats bone and when he was fat or was that when he
was still man?
Yeah,
this is right when he first started being a man.
I guess that he looks now,
he looks pretty charming.
It's really interesting.
Right?
Incredibly interesting.
I mean it's pretty good.
There's so few women to men that uh,
you know,
you hear about,
it's uh,
seems more rare,
right?
Um,
yeah.
He looks like a total dude.
Positive pregnancy.
It was kind of cool.
They can do that to him.
You know,
his whole life wanting to be a man.
Positive pregnancy tests in high demand on craigslist.
I'll read it again.
How crazy is that shit?
Positive pregnancy?
Yes.
So like just to make somebody marry you maybe.
Exactly.
They advertise tests for women hoping to trick their boyfriends into popping the
question.
Wow.
Whoa,
that's crazy.
They're only 25 bucks to 25 bucks.
Positive pregnancy test.
25 bucks in Buffalo,
New York.
Yes.
You saw that,
right?
I'm willing to,
I'm selling positive pregnancy tests.
Ever since I became pregnant.
I have been asked numerous times for a positive test,
so I decided to start charging for it.
Exclamation point.
I will take the test the same day.
You want to pick it up?
I don't care what you use it for.
Not My business.
Wink.
Wow.
I'm always near my phone,
so just send an email.
Wow.
That's kind of crazy.
Some crazy pregnant bitch.
Just pissing on chicks.
Pregnancy tests all day.
That's a business.
25 bucks a pop.
She's got a basket full of them.
Just pass it on.
I'm like crazy drinking giant jugs,
Koolaid pissing all over these fucking things and then like two days before the
wedding you had fake a miscarriage and then everyone buys you better toys and
presents gives you more money because they're so rude.
You're evil.
I don't even think the most evil woman could think that way.
Actually.
They might write my time at holy.
Exactly right,
man.
I had somebody do a fake pregnancy with me once.
Remember that had shit.
It's stupid.
Just so I would give her money.
Yeah.
There's a lot of,
um,
these positive pregnancy tests,
things where they're advertising these things and whether asking for them to
just kind of weird man,
I would buy just the smell them.
How much is that?
$25 a smell.
25 bucks just to smell some random chicks pis.
If you're a real freak,
you might go for it.
Okay.
I wonder if there's that.
You could sell that for 25 bucks.
Here's,
send me a rag and I'll pee on it.
It's not outside the realm of possibility.
It's crazy though.
Manipulation.
It's just some people like that's their,
their relationship was just a constant battle like that.
It's,
uh,
it's gotta be a weird way to enter into a lifelong commitment for fake pregnancy
test.
I mean,
what if it all works out?
You happy you got married?
Then one day sitting around,
she goes,
honey,
I'm gonna tell you something really funny.
I remember when I had that,
uh,
that miscarriage.
I was never really pregnant.
I,
it was fake.
I needed,
I knew you'd be happy eventually.
And so look,
I was right.
Here we are 60 years later.
The guy's like,
she,
I don't care,
honey.
I love you.
It's gotta be the responsibility of being the one who could possibly get
pregnant.
Point is that fucking change the game.
That's why they say that one of the biggest changes in behavior for human beings
was when birth control was invented because then for the first time women had
some sort of control over their own ability to get pregnant or not get pregnant,
their own contraception.
They didn't have to count on like I had to wear a rubber.
That guy doesn't want to wear a rubber.
Otherwise I've got to get like an Iud or a diaphragm and those things fucking
slip out.
Especially if you have a thunderous,
tremendous waterfall of loads slamming into that thing.
They can't take a good shot.
You know,
they're good.
They're good for like the average load,
but you get like a wilt Chamberlain load there.
It just finds its way around.
Hello.
Is that sucker sideways?
Like one of those big revolving doors and Indiana Jones.
That's what does the load hits.
It just
opens it up.
But that was a big change apparently for a women when they,
they had like this new freedom,
like you think it's just fuck around.
They didn't have to worry about,
some guy could just shoot one in there.
Oh my God,
you almost got me pregnant psych.
We've enough to worry about it.
I just can't believe that people still want to get married now days.
I mean it just seems like now that you just know so many people that go in and
get married,
get divorced,
you know,
it's just like,
more people that have been married then that are,
that are married at least.
Yeah.
What you there,
there's always going to be,
um,
a certain amount that are trying to talk you into it too,
which is always weird.
Like you should just get married.
Hey man,
you should settle down.
Get married,
marry the girl.
Go ahead,
Marissa.
You should marry her.
And you're like,
Whoa,
whoa,
hey,
why?
Why,
why to marry people want to drag other people into that fucking shell game.
It's like a call.
I never tell people to get married.
People ask me to get married.
It,
you know,
if,
uh,
they should get married.
I say,
listen,
I enjoy being married,
but it's rare.
It's rare that you do,
you know,
me and the missus rug and get along great.
She's a sweetheart.
She's a really nice person.
We enjoyed talking to each other.
We enjoy raising children together.
We,
we love it.
But that shit's rare,
man.
It's really rare that people don't annoyed.
They'll fuck out of each other.
After a while,
the grill apart,
they start getting annoyed with each other.
They're around each other all the time and then the dark shit happens when you
start breaking up and people start getting mercenary about where the money goes.
People start getting mercenary about the house and it starts becoming a
competition.
I've seen it happen too many times.
I've just,
I've seen it happen way too many times.
For me to think that it's a good idea to get married because the,
the,
the ending of relationships when people just break up aren't nearly as bad.
But the consequences of divorce or just fucking devastating breakup suck.
Nobody likes breaking up.
Nobody likes being depressed.
Nobody likes missing somebody sucks period.
But divorce is break up times a hundred,
maybe more where you become 100% enemies.
Yeah.
Like war.
People go to war man and it gets ugly and you know,
they legally have to still be engaged in this thing you're brought into the
court.
It's like once you get into that court system and you're divvying everything up
inside the court system,
you have to be in their world.
You have to be engaging with the men and women both,
you know,
I'm sure like it equally,
both are equally guilty of wanting the person who wants to leave them to be
forced to pay or it's craziness,
man.
It's madness.
The only time it makes sense is to me when there's children involved and when
the woman has to um,
you know,
it takes a lot of time to raise children.
It takes a tremendous amount of time to be pregnant and give birth to actually
raise the child.
And a woman should be compensated for that.
I think,
you know,
if you,
if you choose to not work at stay home and you're raising children,
there's a big difference between that and a couple that don't have any kids that
are in a relationship,
that breakup and the woman gets smarter scenario because I've seen that too and
that is so much grocer.
That is the grossest shit ever.
When you see a couple and they're just a,
you know,
a man and a woman and they don't have any kids together and they decided to get
married and during the time that they're together and they're in love,
they both work and they,
they split income and then when they go to get divorced,
the mercenary shit that takes place,
the fighting over the house,
the fucking calling the IRS on someone and pretending they owe more money than
they do,
sending an anonymous letters about them.
Like all that kind of craziness starts happening and people become enemies with
each other in a way that doesn't exist in any other kind of relationship.
It's very rare that friends ever do that to each other.
You know?
Like how often do you hear about a friend like suing another friend,
taking a friend to court?
It's pretty rare,
but it almost happens.
It least half of the cases where people decide to get married.
At least half the people I know the decided to do that legal contract thing,
wind up falling apart at least half and when it gets to half it's got to be like
Jesus,
what a crap shoot are you involved in?
Right.
The only time,
the only time it makes sense to me is raising children and even then it doesn't
make sense.
It makes sense that a woman would want it and that they,
they like being able to say it and then like the different classification that
they feel.
It gives the relationship,
but it's a nutty,
nutty way to live tied into this legal system.
The legal system.
You should avoid that motherfucker if at all possible.
Whenever you can avoid being involved in the world of lawyers and paying for
lawyers and going to court Jesus Christ,
avoid that.
Avoid it.
If you can absolutely avoided if you had you take your shit,
I'll take my shit.
Well that's how you're rocking it.
That's how you're rocking it right now.
But then you know there's also the,
you get lonely.
You want them,
you want to know someone like truly and intimately.
And that takes a long time to do,
to really understand someone cause people like they pretend to be something that
they're not and they put on behavior that is like a acceptable,
the beginning,
you know,
because you think they're really unique and then as you get to know them,
you find out it's kind of a bullshit act.
It takes a long time to figure out who's real and who's not and who you really
enjoy hanging out with and talking to.
And you don't get that.
And those fly by night girl just moves in and moves out.
Two months later,
relationships,
you get chaos and eggs thrown at your house and tee shirts stolen.
You get,
you get craziness man.
And that's what you're going to get.
And that sort of a relationship.
So that's the,
that's the rub.
It's like what do you want?
Do you want to get the possibility of being annoyed with each other?
And constant fights,
which we've all seen,
we've all seen it.
We've all seen the legal entanglements that involve when you break up or do you
want to have these fly by night,
20 year old crazy bitches coming in and out of your life.
You don't seem to be enjoying it either.
You see that
doesn't seem to be like the best option either.
You know,
everybody wants to be able to James Bond it.
You've known me and PR a lot of relationships as long relationships.
I have always been one of those people that just likes it.
I think it's comfortable,
you know like having somebody,
even if you know you're not cited or anything like that,
it's just nice to have like somebody with you all the time,
like a a partner.
Like you can go home to you know and stuff.
But I haven't done that for a while though.
Have that somebody or done that.
I kind of miss it though.
It's,
it's a nice feeling if it goes bad,
I've seen it go bad with you.
It's,
yeah,
it's ugly.
It's devastating for your emotional health.
Doesn't feel good.
Yeah,
it's a real problem when you know,
you get really close to somebody and then you start hating each other.
That's a,
that has a real physical effect on you.
You know,
I've,
I've had like the worst shows of my life after breakups,
you know,
the,
the worst shows ever.
Cause it's like you just don't feel funny at all.
He just feel like I'll fucking loser.
I can some of the worst sets I had.
Like when I moved from New York,
uh,
to bought from Boston rather to New York,
I was breaking up with his chick that I had dated in Boston and she really was
done with me before I was really done with her.
So it was like extra ego bruise and um,
and I just decided,
you know,
to,
to get the fuck out of dodge and move to a New Jersey.
Um,
and uh,
the,
uh,
going on stage was so hard cause I was,
nothing was funny to me.
I was just like emotional,
sad case.
I wasn't like,
I didn't,
I didn't understand how to embrace things.
I didn't understand how to embrace the adventure of like,
now I'm going to be doing standup in New York and you know,
Holy Shit,
I'm here.
I moved down,
I'm staying at my grandparents' house in New Jersey.
I was just a terrible mess.
Like terrified about the future.
Bummed out that this girl doesn't want to be with me anymore.
And My sets were terrible because of that for like a while,
like a couple of weeks.
It took me a while,
like sort of get it together,
I get loose again.
That's indicative of like there's an emotional state that breakups put you in.
It's unhealthy.
Yeah.
Especially when I remember my big one when I first moved out here,
I mean I did it for like seven years and I went on complete sadness that,
you know,
like if this is the worst thing in the world for like a month,
then I went revenge,
I'm going to lose a shitload of weight.
And that's when I lost all that weight.
Remember that like,
and it was,
it,
it was so,
I mean,
that lasted a year,
a year of my life probably,
you know,
when it said to done,
I was still like,
what is she doing?
Oh my God,
where's your,
where's yet?
You know,
it's so weird how,
how much connection you get with somebody and then when that's gone it's like
they kind of died.
Like you went from being like,
this is my partner in life.
Too Low.
That person exists though.
Like she's breathing right now.
She's,
yeah.
Do you ever stop and think about like high school girlfriends?
Oh yeah.
That's real weird.
Yeah.
I just talked to one the other day.
Did you really?
Yeah,
she's,
she has daughters now and everything like that.
This is the one that I dated in high school that cheated on me with my best
friend.
And the day of graduation,
she sat with her family,
his family.
So my dad's like,
it where's so and so?
And that was like,
she's over there with Lira,
ted,
Ted parents.
But,
uh,
she,
she's like,
do you have all those pictures?
I mean,
I used to have tons of photos of me and her and he was like,
yeah,
I actually have a on my flicker.
And so she uh,
she wanted me to like print them out or send her links so she could print it out
and look,
show her kids like,
oh,
this is what,
how mommy used to be,
you know.
But it's weird talking to that unit.
That was years ago.
It's weird talking to anybody that you knew from back then that you were friends
with.
But it's really weird.
When I was a girl,
the girl used to date
is that weird thing.
Strange feeling.
You still fuck each other and now here we are 20 years later.
Yeah.
Saying shut up kids,
quiet.
Mommy's on the phone with Brian.
It's not the same person either.
It almost feels like it's a different person.
Of course it is a different person.
You're a different person than when I met you.
Everybody's different,
you know,
if you keep evolving,
you eventually not the same thing that you were just a year ago.
You're not the same thing you were a week ago.
If you have conviction and mean who are you?
You're,
you are what you decided you are right now.
It's whether or not you can maintain that.
You know whether or not you can maintain what you would like to be.
But for a lot of people you're barely the same thing every year.
Every year you're developing sort of new ideas about things,
understanding your faults a little bit better,
understanding where you fuck up a little bit better and trying not to do it.
Being a little bit more disciplined about certain things,
we feel like you've been lacking.
If that happens,
how you're not the same thing you were a year ago,
you're not the same thing you were five years ago.
You're not,
you change,
you're not,
I'm not,
I don't believe half the things that I believed 10 15 years ago.
I look at things totally differently.
Like we were talking about the Hugh Hefner joke now,
like I wouldn't do that joke today.
I wouldn't pick on one guy like that for no reason.
Just cause he's banging some checks.
I would,
I would do it in a different way.
I would do it way less mean.
He's still durable to captain's hat on as level little blankies and swell.
It's the,
here's he was my,
my beef with it and it'll always be this is that he's a pornographer and no one
wants to admit that is for some reason it's like the socially accepted
pornography.
You know,
and I don't think there's anything wrong with pornography,
but I think it's weird that we pretend that if you don't show the vagina that
it's somehow another acceptable well and the difference between that and when
you see like crystal clear,
like hustlers stuff where they're opening their pussy,
that's nasty.
Like to who was this for women is just stuff for women because it's not nasty
for me.
Like what's going on?
And the idea is that playboy has kind of classy.
It's all about the photography.
It's almost like the of a woman compared to like,
hey my pussy fat Holly's listened to you.
You convert.
It's all about the a to the woman he has.
That's the type of shit,
the photographer for those girls.
If photography is where playboy are fucking legit photographer and these people
are like best,
best,
like for anyone who,
was there anything,
she does a lot of stuff for playboy penthouse though.
I mean you're,
you're getting a combination or hustler.
You're getting a combination of good photographers and just guys that not had
that have cameras.
I,
yeah,
the,
see that's what I say.
I don't need a lot of um,
photography skills when it comes to like looking at naked checks.
They have to be clear.
That's a clear picture.
We're good.
I don't know.
You look at somebody like Holly,
Holly Randall is,
I think,
well,
there's definitely a different feeling
is definitely a different feeling to watching something or looking at a magazine
where girls are like pissing in each other's mouths and spreading their assholes
open.
And a girl who's just posing with her mouth slightly agape arching her back hand
and her from ass.
That is different.
Yeah.
Checkout a Holly Randall Dotcom sometimes.
She's one of my favorite female photographers for erotic.
She does a lot of shit for penthouse though.
But uh,
amazing photographer.
Very nice woman to,
um,
I just think that it's,
it's,
it's just weird that people decide what,
what is and what's not acceptable when it comes to pornography.
And it has to do with actually seeing things.
Like we'd like seeing the vagina itself.
Like you don't think vaginas are beautiful.
Do you think that somehow or another that the woman's body is beautiful,
her breasts are beautiful but the vagina is a little much you,
you are in fact wrong.
Okay.
Because vaginas are beautiful ceremony them,
they're delicious,
they look great,
they look great unless there's a problem with it and you know,
look,
it is what it is.
I mean it's not saying that every vagina has to look awesome.
Well we are saying though,
if you take photos of them should probably limit those photos to the ones that
looked pretty good.
But that's just like,
unless you want it to be like a character pace,
if you go on some of these cam websites and you start,
you start singing
and I tell you,
man,
if you like on,
on Myfreecams and you could choose South Africa,
there's usually like four girls on there.
I mean,
there was this one girl had her vagina really looked unhealthy.
That's not pretty sure.
So John Mccain was playing poker on his iPhone while,
uh,
his colleagues were discussing bombing Syria.
They have a photograph of him.
He's sitting there with his iPhone and he's playing poker.
That's hilarious.
It's fucking hilarious,
dude.
Aviva,
you've been following all of this,
right?
You saw all the gas videos where all these people are getting gassed on,
I think it was Ustream stream or something like that.
Somebody was broadcasting it live and people were dying.
Did A,
uh,
have you been paying attention to,
I don't know much,
but did they ever find out who gas?
Was it the government gassing neurone people or was it like,
uh,
some debts,
death squads or something?
Right.
I do not know exactly who,
uh,
who did it.
I know that somebody took,
we should probably Google that because someone took credit for it.
Wow.
That's hilarious.
He does.
But I mean,
where's this coming from?
Yes.
This is when you're playing poker on his iPhone hero.
Wow.
That's hilarious.
Uh,
credit for it.
But you know what?
He's so old that maybe he was just like,
ah,
what do I get?
Deron email up.
What?
I'm trying to like what if he accidentally hit,
you know,
the poker,
you know what I mean?
Like he's playing though.
Oh that motherfuckers locked in.
It's like a still photo.
What's happening?
Good time.
He knows what he wants to do and wants to play poker.
He doesn't want to talk about Syria.
He's been saying let's fucking bomb.
And then it goes right back on another ice SWOT.
Full House bitches.
Look at that.
Eh,
I wouldn't even wait.
I would like to see,
as you know,
if it was him just staring at his phone out,
what does it do?
And like,
it's too old to figure out,
like where does it have my email?
Like,
you know,
old people with technology
who did this.
So I'm still see,
right.
Yeah.
Responsibility.
MMM.
I guess it,
the Syrian rebels,
I don't know.
There's all sorts of uh,
terrible shit going on over there.
This is a,
the same conflict where the guy who,
uh,
was from the,
the people that were backing eight,
the,
the a piece of the man's heart cut out of his chest and ate a chunk of his
heart.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
Who's side are we on?
We're on that guy side.
It kind of sucks though,
because I,
you know,
if we do anything with Syria,
I mean then are we going to get in war with Russia again?
Oh,
I don't know.
Cause Russian has like their last base.
They're like they're big.
Yeah.
Dot.
C.
Who the fuck knows what's really going on behind the scenes in any of these
things,
you know,
I shouldn't say you know anymore.
You know that.
Yeah.
Cause it's another way of saying,
um
hm.
The uh,
documentary that we always talk about or the,
the paper rather that Smedley Butler war is a racket.
It's a guy who lived in the 1930s.
It was a war is a racket,
but naked.
And uh,
he,
um,
yeah,
he wrote this thing in 1935.
It's so crazy because if you're read it today,
it's so poignant.
It's hard to believe really
that,
uh,
that it was actually so long ago they wrote this,
it was a speech and then a booklet that he put out,
it's 51 pages and uh,
it was published in 1935 by round table press.
And,
uh,
the booklet was also a condensed and do a reader's digest as a book supplement.
And it's,
it's,
it's really an impossible message today because if you,
it's so strange that this was actually published in a book in 1935.
It's impossible for us to believe rather than this was the message and it's,
war is a racket.
It's always been,
it's possibly the oldest,
easily the most profitable.
Surely the most vicious is the only one international in scope.
It's the only one in which profits are reckoned in dollars and the losses in
lives.
And this is,
it's a long thing.
And I want to read anymore of it,
but it's fucking brilliant.
And this is a guy that was a major military figure.
He was the United States Marine Corps.
Major General two time medal of honor recipient.
That's pretty crazy.
So when you,
you know,
when you look at that,
that was 1935 and you think,
well,
what has been done about stopping that type of behavior?
Abso-Fucking-Lutely nothing.
Not only that,
it's evolved because everything evolves.
It's not like they've cleaned the house and taking all the people out that were
involved in this type of behavior and educated them on ethics and morals and
humanity and being kind to be evil.
Get the fuck Outta here,
bitch.
They're just better at hiding it.
Better at making money at it and just better at it,
period from whatever this was,
which was almost a hundred years ago now,
which is really crazy.
And it was 80 fucking years ago.
That's God damn,
that's so long ago.
Just wrap your head around that 1935 date.
That's incredible.
80 fucking years ago.
Almost wrap your head around that.
Just think about these people live in back then and this guy comes out with his
book there,
you know,
World War One.
He comes out with his book before World War II.
It was like,
this is just bullshit.
Like they're just going over there to say bankers.
They're just going over here to make it safe for the oil companies.
There's going over here and they're pretending that they're the fucking saving
the world.
When you read that,
there's no reason to believe that anything has changed,
so when you see the serious shit,
you got to go,
I don't know,
man.
All I know is Ron Paul's not buying it.
GRANDPA's not Ron.
Paul thinks it's some,
he thinks that that would be ridiculous to a attack.
Those people with gas like that,
he thinks it's somebody who wants to drag us into ward.
Did that because that would be the reason why people would be willing to accept
another war.
It would take something along those lines and to make it so big and so public.
He said,
why would they do that?
You know?
He said,
I believe that it's a false flag.
When you hear a guy like Ron Paul say something like that.
I mean,
who would know?
You know,
I think Ron Paul might know.
Hmm.
Goddammit Brian.
Now you got me scared.
Did you see that video of that boulder falling down?
Yes.
Yeah.
Life is fucking terrifying.
That's ridiculous.
Where was this?
It looks like something.
Yeah.
So yeah,
but this kind of reminds me of like,
you know where you're driving in Malibu,
you know you've driven that road.
Uh,
and I guess you can see it like fall loose from the mountain right before it
suddenly
waterfall just starts or something.
Well,
it absolutely can happen in Malibu and it does look at that.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Oh my God.
Look at this big fucking,
oh,
you almost died.
That is incredible.
That's so loony tunes.
It's so big.
And then he hit their hazards.
So polite Japanese [inaudible] Japanese people.
If that was a,
an American,
they'd be going,
fuck gun CIF fucking fucking cunt.
Wow.
This is crazy.
Boom.
And that could happen any day that got Malbec.
Look at that.
That car almost got smushed.
Well,
Malibu Canyon has been closed several times since I've lived here.
I thought about living in Malibu before.
Malibu's fucking beautiful man.
You're out there on the mountain overlooking the ocean.
It's so beautiful.
And the people there are chill.
There's something about being like right by the water.
I think that does something to a person.
All beach communities are chill,
you know,
they like to have fun,
relax.
It feels like a born more enjoy life type of vibe.
I would love to do it.
But the problem Malibu is,
it's a bunch of crazy rich people popping pills.
They're
bringing their dog everywhere.
Like they'll bring the dog in a restaurants and shit and like kids in Mal.
But like if you want to raise your kids there,
that Malibu high,
apparently I hear,
uh,
there's uh,
they have,
uh,
a few behavioral problems there with some of the substances while you shit
homeschool your kids Joe
podcast and they'll learn every day,
you know,
just start off and like,
maybe an eight or seven and just bring them to the podcast every day.
There'll be smarter than anybody else.
Well,
what's a,
a better idea is,
uh,
show them some oxycontin documentary very early in life.
Show them the oxycontin express and say,
look,
this is some shit you want to avoid and you're not even going to believe it's
possible until you see someone smoking it in front of you.
You're not going to believe like,
no,
there's no one's stupid enough to smokes.
I oxycontin at a party.
Oh yes there is and you're probably going to run into him.
I ran into people doing coke at parties.
I ran into a course run into people smoking pot.
I've ran into people eating mushrooms.
I've ran into people dropping acid at parties.
I ran into like basically almost anything except math at parties.
I probably ran into people on math.
I just didn't know they were out of math.
Absolutely.
But that's the key.
You got to let them know,
like bring him around.
People that are fucked up,
let them know like this is real.
Like you gotta listen to me because this really can take over your life.
There's really can grab
a hold of you and drag you right into a chemical hell that you can't get out of.
There is some shit that you can do that you can't undo you fucking cigarettes,
man.
You bummed me out dude.
I would hate to see you die like that cause it's going to happen.
If you keep going.
It's going to be,
there's a moment,
whether it's 10 years from now or 20 years from now and you're one of these put
it off guys like,
oh do all quit before that.
I'll quit before that.
But you're taking like giant chunks off the end of your life.
You're taking giant chunks off your health giant chunks of your ability for your
lungs to function correctly and it's just because you're stuck.
You're in this chemical,
this chemical web that you just can't get out of.
Yeah,
it's,
it's pretty amazing.
It's pretty amazing.
What does electronic cigarettes though,
man,
so many people are fucking smoking those things.
Joey d is less than though.
The worst though is those ain't shit.
Ain't shit.
I don't even want a regular cigarette dog.
This is just vapor.
Is it,
what is the deal though?
We,
we,
we've been disputed about that.
We said that a tobacco companies own those things.
Yeah.
So apparently it is true.
Maybe,
but most tobacco companies apparently trying to lobby against them because
they're hurting cigarette sales.
Yeah.
But uh,
what'd I say?
The second largest one owns blue or whatever it was.
I mean the other ones like get the fuck outta here with that.
Yeah.
It's probably an old guy that owns like a company versus a new,
you know,
somebody who died from lung cancer in the sun just got the company.
I was like,
no,
we're investing in these robots.
Cigarettes with the lights.
Apparently the cost effectiveness is an issue as well.
Like those uh,
those things they last for like a long time.
Like a blue one of those cigarettes.
Rechargeable.
Yeah,
the rechargeable and the amount of a cigarette in them like is good for a long,
it's like two packs of cigarettes,
usually some of these.
And now you get those humongous hookah ones where it's pretty much like,
like a,
like a s a two liter of that juice.
And you just see these people sucking on it all day.
Just smoke.
Just nonstop coming out of their mouth.
Bobby Lee?
Yeah.
Bobby Lee.
Pj on.
If you remember PTA.
Bobby Lee has one that's as big as a thermos.
Yes.
What PJ?
It's insane and he just sucks on that thing all the time.
He's got stickers all over it.
Bobby has stickers all over the,
the new candy cigarette man.
The kids want them because they look cool because of the lights fucking instead.
It's just another way to get people addicted to fucking cigarettes or putting
things in their mouth.
Yeah.
Well it's also just a nicotine distribution device.
When we,
when Marin was in here and we saw him eating that,
that gum,
he eats that gum all day long.
That nicorette.
Right.
I guess that's okay though.
They say that the Nicorette gum actually is good if your writing,
we try that Nicorette Gum.
It's actually stimulating for like a your synapses and shit.
It's disgusting.
Is it?
Yeah,
it,
it tastes like you're eating chemicals.
Marin ain't got no problem with it.
He loves that Shit.
Chu Chu Chu,
he eats it like big league chew.
I'm supposed to have like one o'clock.
Yeah,
he's got them all in his mouth all day.
He goes,
he's chained you.
Yeah.
Can you change you?
Of course you can.
How bad is that Shit for you?
Do they know it's not that bad for you that,
that,
that it's just,
you know,
cause you're not supposed to eat it every day.
You're supposed to actually quit smoking.
They say nicotine though.
I is actually like a supplement and nicotine itself.
Not only is it not bad for you,
it's the distribution device that fucks you up.
The burning it and chemicals and those chemicals designed to enhance the
addictive qualities of a tobacco.
But they say that if you can get your nicotine like a liquid form,
it actually has positive health benefits.
Yeah,
it's relaxing.
It makes,
it said that's not true.
I believe you,
but it doesn't make me relax.
The only nicotine,
uh,
I ever get is in the form of cigars and uh,
it makes my
and heart rush.
What?
That's that you're,
you're taking in so much nicotine?
Yeah.
Because it's like cigarette times a million.
You get high as fuck.
Yeah,
and it's still,
you still get it and right when it hits your cheeks,
you're getting that smoke in your mouth.
People don't know.
They don't want to admit that you're getting high when you're smoking a cigar.
It's the reason why men like smoking cigars just not just to be stinky and to
keep women away.
You know?
It's not like bug spray for women.
No,
it gets you high.
It gets your grow like crazy too.
It's like you're doing bong hits.
I've cigarettes pretty much is what you're doing.
What do you think about girls and smoke cigars?
I got an odd thing.
Dangerous cal little,
an untied tie,
you know,
like she was about to take it off guard.
She takes her hat and puts it on the ship.
Glasses on.
Fuck.
Yes.
Yeah,
she stepped glasses for sure.
Just glasses,
but no under that.
She's a bad girl.
Very back.
Just chef garter belts on.
You know,
she has one that she's about to pull off,
but yeah.
Okay.
Now you just got,
yeah,
she one,
but to pull off,
women have all sorts of little things that they get to wear to enhance like
shoes that make the legs longer and
fish nets and
men are pretty much resigned to close,
but women have closed that will offer real sexual suggestion.
You know,
like those,
first of all,
women are allowed to wear sleeveless shirts pretty much everywhere.
We're like,
yeah,
yeah.
No worries.
Just you'd have to have sleeves,
take your sleeves off,
but if a man goes around with no sleeves,
if a man goes around with no sleeves,
that guy's a douche bag.
You know,
if a man walks around in a tank top,
he's a meathead and a douchebag.
But women every day go sleeveless.
Like you go to a normal office and women or sleeveless on a regular basis.
I fucking hate those wife beater tank tops.
Things like jam band here.
Jam Band wears it all the time
and it's like,
oh,
thanks.
Now I can see a puff of armpit hair.
I guess we have a problem with my man here.
I don't need to see your little baby bushes.
Yeah,
you're just not manly enough handle it.
You're not manly enough for a tank top,
but it's,
it's,
it implies a Douche genus.
It's unavoidable at this point.
And in our society,
when you wear a tank top,
she looked douchey.
Even if you're trying not to,
it sucks,
but it's unavoidable.
You know,
it's like you're trying a little too hard.
Just a wee bit too hard lot.
But Women Shit,
they could wear tank tops everywhere.
This is a story about this very,
very,
very large crocodile trap.
The tourist for two weeks.
Yeah,
I read about that.
It was a,
he said it was something like 18 feet long and every time he went out into the
water,
it would pop up and start head towards him.
And he was like,
fuck that.
Want to feet long?
It head back to shore 20,
they just killed two of the biggest alligators they've ever killed in
Mississippi.
They broke the world record,
uh,
the Mississippi rather record twice in a day.
They cut two of them that were over 700 pounds.
She's got to see the pictures of him.
Holy fucking shit.
They're giant.
You know the,
the picture has the caption dinosaur.
Also dinosaurs are real,
you know,
let you know,
like these are real animals.
These are gigantic lizards.
Put that picture up.
Oh shit man.
27 minutes ago there was a 6.5 earthquake in Japan.
Oh Christ.
Are you kidding me?
Oh fuck man.
Like five dude.
Where in Japan is zoo islands east?
It's so scary.
I can show you this.
It Fukushima gets hit again.
There are fucked and we're fucked to California's fucked.
Oh Shit.
This idea of putting together a fucking nuclear reactor right by the ocean and
not having a way to shut it off.
If the waves come over the top of where you anticipated it.
What a shit idea.
It's amazing that anybody ever let them do this right.
And cocoa and there's so many of these fucking things that are all over our
coasts as well.
And I'm like,
well,
these are better,
these are made better,
and these are,
we have fail safes,
failproof safes,
and make sure that this is not going to be a thing of concern,
but we have done as establish a series of protocols and case of an emergency.
Well,
we have to shut down the rare bitch.
If the shit hits the fan,
the shit hits the fan.
Okay?
If a fucking asteroids slams in the middle of the ocean and a giant thousand
foot wave comes over and knocks that motherfucker down or rips all the fucking
ground out underneath,
it fucks up all the electrical system that's connecting all your cooling
bullshit and just you have an an unapproachable area.
Now you have a fucking gigantic nuclear reactor that's melting down into the
earth itself,
leaky in the ocean.
That's what they have in Japan.
I fucking thing's like billions of gallons of toxic water into the ocean.
They're showing an increase in the level of radiation that are in fish.
It's just started.
That stuff is good for hundreds of thousands of years.
This is such a terrifying environmental disaster and it's just happening.
And no one even knows what the fuck do about it.
And I think it's if,
if the government really wants to act and Syria,
you know,
diff protect us,
why the fuck aren't they over there doing everything they can to stop this
nuclear reactor from leaking into the ocean?
Why don't we put all our resources right?
All of them,
all of them,
like literally everything.
Try to figure out all the,
all of our budget,
everything we,
you got to save the planet right now you've got something that's leaking toxic
waste in the planet and people say,
I'm exaggerating.
And not from what I looked at from what I looked at online and actual tasks,
they've shown an increase,
a measurable increase in the radioactive qualities of fish and they've showed
that this,
this toxic waste,
it's leaking is a significant disaster and it's not stopping.
I was talking to you,
remember my friend Coco,
you know,
in Tokyo and I was talking to this the other day,
I've been sending her news things,
news reports of all their recent,
you know,
shit or finding out and it was new to her.
She was like,
and half the shit she couldn't,
it was blocked.
Like she couldn't even look at these news stories from Tokyo.
She's like,
what is it?
And so I would send her screenshots and,
and like she was like,
oh well they weren't getting this news.
She acted like they were not getting the news that she had no,
no idea about any of this.
And then she was,
you know,
it was so weird to hearing her,
like we,
you know,
the old people built this country and we have to respect them and help them,
and stuff like that.
Like how,
and then finally I just kept on sending more and more and she's like,
ah,
yeah that's sucks.
What am I supposed to do?
And I feel kind of bad cause he's in there,
you know,
she's eating the fish everyday,
she's breathing that right?
She's getting what we're going to get next year and we're acting like this isn't
a big asteroid that's flying towards earth that's about to hit.
We were just like,
oh this sucks.
Look at these cute maps.
Like we should be throwing space shuttles in the ocean or whatever we can do to,
to figure out that quick
cause yeah.
I don't know how they have to be good next year.
Yeah.
One of the things they're talking about is building this gigantic $400 million
ice wall.
Have you seen that?
No.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Pull that up.
Building ice wall and Fukushima.
It's uh,
it seems like a hail Mary Man.
I don't know if it really works that way.
What if though,
what if I mean,
but isn't like Hawaii.
You're going to get this in six.
Oh yeah,
they already got it.
Oh,
Yeah,
they already got it.
Hawaii without a doubt has gotten some of the radiation.
No doubt.
If you look at the plume of radioactive waste that's coming off of it,
Japan to spend over $300 million on ice wall to isolate Fukushima water leak.
I've seen it here.
It says on the BBC it says 470 million said Japan
has pledged 470 million for this ice wall.
Who gives a fuck how much it is.
So crazy idea.
Yes.
Time.
It sounds like science fiction,
massive underground wall of ice,
so cold,
so strong,
it stops hundreds of tons of radioactive water seeping out of Fukushima power
plant tanks and into the Pacific.
This is no movie.
It is a $320 million emergency plan announced today by the Japanese government.
Wow.
Here's how it would work in above ground refrigerator chills a coolant to minus
40 degrees Fahrenheit.
That icy liquid gets pumped into steel pipes dug below the crippled plant,
just like a kitchen freezer.
Everything around those pipes also freezes a giant wall of ice forms stretching
nearly a mile long and nearly 10 stories below ground about the height of the
Lincoln Memorial.
Some scientists say this may just be a short term fix,
but something has to be done soon before there's even greater damage to the
environment and Japan's economy,
right?
It might not be as much way to activities Chernobyl,
but for the ocean is unprecedented as an accidental source.
We've never seen this much radiation coming out of a reactive site directly into
the ocean.
But there has been nothing like the size and scope of the wall to come for
Fukushima,
where radiation levels are a staggering 18 times higher than previously thought
enough to kill a person after just four hours of exposure.
So what does this mean for the fish that makes its way to us?
Waters from Japan so far.
That's fucked up.
Well listen to that
found any unsafe levels of radiation.
But with these constraints,
rakes,
scientists say we'll come and increasingly sharper.
Look at the fish we eat and the waters they swim in.
Cecilia Vega,
ABC News,
Los Angeles.
Wow.
Fuck.
I mean so Colorado or Texas?
Colorado.
Oh No.
Texas.
No.
Cotton.
Texas.
Yes.
100% taxes.
Hi Austin.
Yeah,
but Texas is got more the most protection of any state gun wise.
Yeah.
That's not what you need to worry about.
It's like being in a base compared to,
I don't know man.
I feel like there's a lot of secrets in Denver,
like underground missiles and stuff like that.
And I think that's going to be a target.
That's all you silly bitch.
You don't think so?
No.
No,
I don't think so.
I don't think anybody's targeting Denver.
I think this is Wacko conspiracy theory.
I think they just built a really sophisticated airport with a lot of tunnels in
it.
I'm done with snow.
I can't do it.
So maybe,
uh,
Austin and a winner and I think I could do the winter in boulder.
I really do.
Or Evergreen or any of those mountain towns.
I think I could do it.
I think you just got to just change how you look at life.
I think the winter just becomes a different thing.
Austin food versus Houston or awesome food versus Denver food.
Austin
women versus Denver Women.
You real estate versus Denver real estate,
real estate's pretty commensurate.
Anytime I can use the word commensurate I do.
Um,
I think it's pretty similar,
you know,
I mean,
they're both,
they're both desirable places to live.
We need to get his closest to Alex Jones as possible too.
Hmm.
That's important.
Maybe we could have a show on the Alex Jones network.
We can move to Austin.
We don't need to get her own studio.
We just take over at night.
That'd be awesome.
Totally.
I'm sure it hits,
people thinks that I don't like him cause I,
I goof on him,
but I just,
I just goof on him because I can do as voice or buddy.
We love that guy.
I actually legitimately hang around with Alex Jones.
Like legitimately I'm not bullshitting.
I'm not a,
I'm not trolling.
Oh he's a great guy.
Fun Guy to party with.
He's a,
he's hilarious.
He says a lot of funny shit and he's exposed me to a lot of stuff.
That's the old school green room man.
They fucked up when they taped over that painted the whole thing.
Oh,
I don't know why they did that.
Oh and push the private presence.
So the drug dealers,
the criminals go rob houses to get the money for the drugs.
Then Alex Jones
Disney up the documents,
but black helicopters can trails and tower seven went down.
[inaudible]
don't try it again.
I want to live right next to Alex charms.
I want to hang out with Alex Jones every single day.
Well,
we could do that if we relocated to Texas.
I'd have to convince Mrs Rogan.
The other problem with Texas is a Austin is bad ass.
Houston's Badass.
Dallas is bad ass,
but damn,
there's some spooky spots in the middle.
There's some spooky drive through areas where you get out,
you get out and just take a right and go straight and then get out and start
talking to people and you're a Goddamn Texas chainsaw massacre moon.
Same Shit here though.
You go up bigger and competent to go up.
You're in the fucking farm in the middle of California where there's fucking
assessed.
That's a good point.
It is a good point.
Especially about the middle of a California,
California spots were
driving up to San Francisco.
Those farms with the Republican sayings on the signs to see drivers.
We won't educate.
They paper right here.
Fucking put up a sign.
Yeah.
You know,
do you really want Obama?
Is your president?
Do you really think he was born in the United States?
Like there's a whole series of them.
When Mitt Romney was running for president,
they were hilarious.
They were so stupid.
It might as well be Kentucky.
Nothing wrong with Kentucky if you live there and love,
but let's be honest,
the techies,
nice man.
A lot of people weren't nice.
Nice.
Louisville's Nice West Virginia at me,
man.
I'm okay with the Little Ville.
Improv was fucking bad ass.
That was a great place to work at.
It was really fun.
I love that place.
Yeah,
but look,
the reality is the world's changing and all those places that sucked 20,
30 years ago,
they suck less now.
If people have internet,
they just do people getting thing.
A kids high school kids are getting it more than they've ever been there.
There'll be exposed to more ideas and they've ever been before.
It's less,
sucks less to live somewhere that sucks now than at any other time in human
history.
That said,
Texas is still illegal weed Gestapo like police tactics.
Has there been any of rest of the Willie Nelson and they arrested?
Um,
what's her name?
The fucking shadow dancer.
It tells her name.
Fiona Apple.
Ooh,
she saw that.
I gave her my seat on a plane ones.
Yeah,
it was her.
I just want to sit next to her sister and she asks this lady to do it and the
lady wouldn't move.
She goes,
no,
this is my seat.
It's like,
Whoa,
snap.
Yeah.
That was right behind.
So I swapped with that.
After you first did right here,
you can sit on my lap.
Oh,
you,
I cleared off a place on my face for set.
Maybe you're going to be in Texas sooner or where did you already did that?
No.
Yeah,
I'm going to be in Houston.
Lucky son.
That's,
um,
October 18th.
He fucking Ha.
Just one night though.
Yeah.
Just one night.
It's the night before the UFC was the UFC and Houston done the Austin?
Nope.
To the comedy club.
Maybe.
That'd be awesome.
The problem is I do the theater.
I'm like Austin City La.
That's like 2000 seats plus fine.
Yeah,
but it's,
it's,
it's harder for me to do that with kids.
It's harder for me to get away with four full weekends.
You know,
he bumps you out,
man with a three year old tells you they miss you.
Like,
oof.
That's hard,
man.
Duct tape,
Nothing.
Changes it more
I think.
Yep.
It was a bad one.
Nothing changes it more than a little babies you have with the adventures of
iPads and stuff.
It's not the same dude.
It's not the same.
They miss you.
They want to hug you.
It's,
it becomes a real borrower.
Like you get you gotta I just gotta have to optimize my time.
I don't like,
like the problem.
I liked doing some comedy club weekends,
but it's all about like if I,
if I,
if it's a UFC weekend with,
the easiest thing about it is I get to do both.
I can do comedy one night and then I'd do the UFC the next night if I'm going to
do,
uh,
like cab city,
like cap,
CD,
I would do like Friday,
Saturday,
Sunday or Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday,
Sunday.
It's a lot of days I get the same amount of people in there.
Yeah,
there's a lot of benefits to it.
The big benefit is that your act becomes bulletproof after like five shows,
you know,
because you do a lot of shows,
like that's the best way to tighten up for a comedy special.
Do a lot of like two,
300 seat clubs.
Like everything just gets so tight it gets so like you just know the timing and
it just gets razor sharp.
Yeah.
By the way I tip,
I think,
I don't know if you agree with me is that if you're always looking to add a
weekend of like comic,
always go for the Sunday one show Sunday.
It's like an eight o'clock show because not only is there usually a longer show
cause there's not a sh a second show after it,
but it's also a that much perfected show I think.
You know like cause like what?
Like you're saying you're there Friday side.
If you're going to see a show with the stage,
you're comfortable at times.
Sometimes the energy is different though.
Sometimes the energy of people on a Sunday night,
they're a little bit more laid back.
Where's the like hyped up on Friday and Saturday and true.
Part of the going to a comedy club is also people around you laughing hard.
That's a weird thing about comedy is it's very contagious.
But that's the thing about having a giant crowd as opposed to having a small
crowd when the crowd is literally 10 times larger than the average car,
like a 3000 seater that even you have to be like first of all you have to be
really on top of the timing of the thing because who they have to really
understand what you have to know when to,
when to talk and when to let them laugh cause they might not be able to hear you
as clearly cause there's so many people and then you also got to realize that
like the contagious element of it is not as strong.
The contagious element of like a comedy clubs incredibly infectious.
Like you're on top of each other.
It's a low ceiling and the laughters rang out.
It's like Ah.
It just,
it like literally like takes over your body.
It's like a better experience.
We can't get as many people into a place
but some people their,
their style is better suited for a big crowd.
Some people have a different style.
They have like a bigger,
broader style and that style does not do well in intimate environment.
You know?
That's,
that's interesting too.
I just think that it feels better.
It feels like when you're on a big stage,
it's amazing how many people are there,
but you're kind of like yelling out into this empty blackness.
You know,
like if you're at a comedy club,
you feel like you can like see faces and it feels just the whole feeling of,
you know,
you can feel everybody's smile I most at you or frown.
Yeah,
I know what I mean.
Totally.
Well,
you can only like a place like the ice house.
He could basically see everybody's face.
Yeah.
The entire club.
Everybody who's there,
you could see their face.
You know when you were in a place like the place I just did in Milwaukee,
the PAPP's theater and can't see shit.
You know,
you're just like,
ah.
Yeah.
There's the video of me going on.
Says you can't see shit.
You can,
you have a giant spotlight in your face.
You're,
uh,
there's,
there's three rows,
three levels,
the mid level and upper level.
You can't see shit.
She a little bit,
you know it's,
it's not,
it's not the same intimate thing.
But we were so lucky like the crowds come to see us are so fucking nice that
I've seen some of those big shows for other people go off the rails if they have
rude audience members.
But Dave Chappelle,
I saw that man that went completely off the rails.
I don't know what happened.
I wasn't there to see the actual off the rail.
I just saw the videos.
The videos seem to pick it up like sorta halfway into being off the rails.
But he's been opening up for him.
She every show he's been on the right of you.
That's probably the problem saying that with Brody's going crazy is the thing
called,
what is it called?
Aloe.
Aloe phrenia.
Yeah,
I think it's called Al Phrenia.
And the idea is that if you have schizophrenia and I hang around with you,
I start developing like weird symptoms and they bring me in for treatment
because they bring me in for you know,
examination because I think I would develop schizophrenia from hanging out with
schizophrenia and that's really possible.
Really?
Yes.
Yeah.
It's a real disease.
I'll Google it.
Wow.
Aloe phrenia you know,
I was reading some shit the other day because people were saying that I am
starting to look like you.
And there was like,
there's like,
I forget where it was,
but like this thread that was like 20 pages long and there was breaking it down
to,
they're like,
no,
there's actually this thing where you hang out with people enough.
You start not,
you're not realizing you're mimicking like muscles in your face to kind of,
uh,
to,
to copy them.
Kind of like that.
And the more you do it,
the more your actual face structure changes into a looking more and more like
the person.
That's why like married couples start,
you know,
when they get older they start kind of looking alike and stuff like that.
And it was an interesting,
I don't know if it's real or not,
but it's interesting.
I would like to figure that out more.
Yeah,
that is interesting.
I know that women when they're around each other for a long time,
they will,
um,
they will change certain things like their,
their periods getting sync,
which is a really freaky,
yeah.
Ties with me.
Ras Al Phrenia.
Do you guys have the same period but periods here?
This,
this says less than normal mental development.
So this is,
I'm looking at the wrong,
sorry.
This all,
oh,
all lego friends.
Yeah,
a low forever.
So yeah,
I can't find that Ella phrenia except okay.
Huh.
I can't find it.
And if I keep looking like this,
it's just going to eat up a lot of time and people are going to be like,
you know what dude,
I don't like listening to podcasts where people just fucking eat up time looking
for the definition of aloe.
Phrenia how phrenia I don't know if that fucking wall of ice is gonna work out,
but I'm worried about that and I'm worried about moving somewhere and I'm not
joking because I think that if the shit does hit the fan,
everyone's going to be looking at it like sort of last minute going,
Holy Shit,
where do we go?
But if this fails and it becomes like a real issue,
like the water's being toxic and thyroid cancer and all sorts of things that go
along with radioactive poisoning and we have that issue.
How long would it take to evacuate the west coast?
I mean,
Ge is us.
No,
you know how fucking crazy that would be if they have to evacuate the west
coast.
Yeah.
I mean,
well they would start with Japan first.
I would have hope.
But uh,
yeah.
But the thing is that,
is this something that,
that people thought in the 60s you know,
is this something that everyone's panicking,
we're reading news reports that are,
you know,
like we have Neil degrasse Tyson and here's like,
everything's fine.
It's fine.
This is,
I mean,
these are mainstream news reports.
This is the BBC.
Yeah.
And this is talking about,
um,
this Fukushima ice wall mean.
This is not,
I think it's pretty much across the board uniformly agreed that this is a real
issue.
Obviously it's a real issue.
I mean,
they just said he could die in four hours if you're there
just seems weird that the planet isn't capable of justice taking that out.
Well,
you know what I mean?
The planet,
it's not going to,
the problem is that people live on the planet.
Yeah.
It'll,
it'll poison the environment for a few hundred thousand years.
But we don't understand this for a few hundred thousand years for the planet.
It ain't shit.
It doesn't matter.
Plan doesn't care.
The dinosaurs 65 million years ago,
the planet is still here and fine long after dinosaurs are dead.
Yeah.
It's got a new thing,
running things and the new thing,
it's fucking things up by digging holes and pulling out oil and putting up these
plants that split Adams and sometimes they go bad poison the entire ocean and,
but 200 years to the ocean ain't shit.
It's just to us that sucks.
It's to us that we could poison every person on this planet and the Earth would
eventually write itself and some new life form would emerge.
And that would happen.
And it may happen.
It may happen just how the dinosaurs did it.
It may be a pandemic virus,
it may be a virus from space.
That's also a possibility.
And maybe something that someone brings back from space.
It may be something that came in and an asteroid like that movie the thing,
you know,
that's possible.
It's not probable,
but it's possible.
It's also possible.
And asteroid can hit and just annihilate the planet.
Just like his happened many times in the past,
65 million years ago,
12,500 years ago,
a hundred,
200 million years before that,
there's been a gang of those.
They've happened more than once.
Giant fucking rocks come in and boom,
that could easily fuck the whole party up.
So that could easily make it so it doesn't matter if you,
uh,
be clean up the ocean.
It doesn't matter if there's a big rock coming,
just open your window,
stick your ass out and take a shit.
Okay cause you got two weeks left and this giant rocks going to hit everything.
It doesn't matter if there's a gigantic pyramid of shit out your bedroom window,
it really doesn't matter.
You're going to die.
Everything's going to be rewritten.
The entire process is going to start a new,
that'd be awesome if like they have to like really take everyone out of Japan
and so like why would that be on the United States offers?
He's like,
Hey,
we'll take all the women
out of nowhere.
It's just easiest Asian population.
That'd be cool.
I think if Japan needs to be evacuated,
we have to evacuate California too.
Dude.
Yo.
Yeah,
I think it's probably going to be in New York state of mind.
I think Denver's not enough away from the ocean.
I don't know if anything's far off away.
I don't know if Texas is far enough away.
It's a different kind notion though,
right?
For the most part it's not tucked in and blocked by the whole con,
uh,
whatever.
I mean it's a different,
see that's affecting you,
but that one's all fucked up too.
That one's all fucked up from the BP oil spill,
but it's warmer.
Do.
Yeah,
it's warmer and it's also connected to Mexico and those people sneaking across
every day try live in uh,
right outside of a of Juarez.
Good luck with that.
You might as well.
We live in next to the most dangerous spot in the world.
Oh,
guess what you are.
You are living right next door to the most dangerous spot in the world.
War has a super dangerous,
and it's just a wall,
just a wall over there across the river,
the Rio Grande Day,
while you're protected in Austin,
they,
you know,
you're not protected.
That's just a few hours drive when it's fucking God.
Guns and shit.
Yeah.
Some people have guns,
but you don't.
So with differences May,
can I go over someone's house?
Hey Man,
let me use your gun.
They're going to shoot.
You know,
I'll be dating a girl that has a gun.
Oh,
there you go.
You're going to be taken care of by a woman.
You're just the opposite of the Huffington post story.
You get underneath the bed.
Brian,
I've got to take care of these shoes.
These genius for you.
Oh God,
Dude.
What is the jigger?
What does a Jig or what are you talking about?
I don't know.
It seems like that's like a racial slur.
Jiggers it's not,
but doesn't it sound like I've got an old thing?
Like there's no,
you are retarded,
dude.
You're going Oh,
too far now.
That wasn't supposed to be racist.
It is though.
It seems like a twig and word is,
but no,
it doesn't.
Seems like you're saying nigger with a j.
That's what it seems like.
Dummy.
How dare you?
It's probably a,
well,
it's a term for fishing.
You'd Jig for fish for like,
so like if this,
if this does really become a problem,
would you ever move to New York?
Fuck No.
That might be the spot to move too.
Fuck.
Quite quite realistically though.
That might be the spot to move to.
Yeah.
Hell,
I'd rather go to Canada.
I will be up in Canada.
It's see you later.
Chandler is not a bad idea,
but the problem with Canada is the West Coast Canada is where it's warm.
So you'd want to live there and that is right by the ocean.
So that's just as bad as living in Alaska,
just as bad as living in Washington.
The oceans bad.
The idea is that if all of this really plays out and people start getting
cancer,
start getting really sick,
it's,
you know,
it's everything by the ocean.
You gotta get the fuck away from the ocean,
you know,
that's a real possibility.
This is,
I mean we're talking like it's nonsense.
Like this is like almost like a story we have to do this soon.
Like a year,
Gerald,
this is when it's supposed to hit la.
We're pretty much have a slow moving asteroid coming to us and we have to figure
out if we want to just enjoy the asteroids and half Shitty,
you're going to fix it.
We're gonna fix it all.
It's amazing that like Malibu could be a poison ocean within the decade.
Like if this motherfucker keeps leaking and the plume keeps just going across
the ocean and headache towards Malibu,
like people are saying it could be a mass extinction event.
Right now there's people going,
well you're doing is fear mongering.
You don't know enough to be,
you're right.
I don't know enough,
but the scary scary story that I read online is it could be a mass extinction of
that worst case scenario.
Let's Google it.
Worst case scenario,
I think it would be more like a slow moving extinction like meaning like you
have to get out of Japan,
are you going to die?
There's going to be all these like,
like respect,
like this is our country.
I'm going to stay here and then they're going to slowly die from health
problems,
but,
and they're okay.
This is what I said.
I said,
what is the worst case scenario?
Right,
so I go to,
okay,
telegraph.
Is that a legitimate site in the UK?
I think it's actually,
I don't think,
I don't know.
It seems like,
I want to say it's like an inquiry.
Okay,
well all these websites are saying the worst case scenario already happened.
Scientific American.
Okay.
That's a legit website,
right?
Our some say rt news.
National geographic.com.
Okay.
National Geographic is saying,
okay.
Oh,
it's actually saying it's far from the worst case scenario for a nuclear plant.
Wait a second.
We haven't even like,
it's probably worse now with this earthquake.
Yeah.
Oh no doubt about it.
But we may only have like a week Joe.
Like people outside are probably running.
Yeah,
they're running across the ocean right now because the ocean is hard.
Yeah.
The rating sounds ominous to be sure,
but its real meaning and the significance of the Japanese official decision to
make a more dire assessment of the crisis are like many other ramifications of
the ongoing crisis.
A few Fukushima,
frustratingly unclear in some respects.
It's not that big of an issue.
What they call it explained David Locke Baum,
a veteran nuclear engineer who works as a safety advocate for the union of
concerned scientists.
He says it's still the same mess.
Um,
why the rating now workers for the Tokyo Power Company,
which operates a plant discovered on the 19th of August,
that 300 tons,
72,000 gallons of highly radioactive water apparently had escaped from a holding
tank into the ground over the previous month.
The water had been used to cool when a Fukushima's damaged reactors and in the
wake of the 2011 earthquake and tsunami caused one of the worst nuclear
accidents and history scientists taken from containment area showed it to be so
heavily contaminated with strontium 90 and celsion one 37 and radioactive
substances that a person's standing less than two feet away would receive in an
hour's time,
a radiation dose equivalent to five times the acceptable exposure for nuclear
workers within 10 hours and exposed person would develop radiation with symptoms
such as nausea and a drop in white blood cells.
But that other thing said that this might be less recent because the other thing
said that four hours,
the thing that we looked at,
it said in four hours you could die.
Right.
So it was saying that it must be several times stronger than the previous
assessment,
which this must be based on,
which is like that's really dire.
Like we have to recognize that this is something that we really need to consider
because it seems like a plot in the movie.
It seems like something that's playing out on TV,
just like Syria,
just like Egypt.
It seems like something that's on TV.
Fuck man.
So my vote Texas,
even though they have like I think three or four nuclear plants in Texas.
Yeah.
But there's a lot of dummies in Texas too,
man.
There's a lot of really cool people too though.
Like the reality of Austin is an island of awesome people.
Yeah.
They have great food.
There was a great stunt sauce and he just,
he would say,
you know,
Houston has some good spots.
Um,
I think what's really cool about Austin is that it has a great art scene.
It's got a great music scene.
A lot of funny comics would come out of Austin.
He's got a couple of great comedy clubs.
Small Club.
Was it that Velveeta Room?
That's the small players.
Yeah.
They have a bunch of little satellite gigs that you could do if you live in
town,
you know,
like,
uh,
you could,
you could actually work in Austin.
You can get some work done as a comic.
So you would not,
you're never going to go back to Japan.
Obviously,
nope.
Nope,
nope,
nope.
That's it.
Is Ufc going?
I don't know.
Um,
I hope if they do,
everybody's safe,
but I've seen,
it seems to me that that is a risk that's a unnecessary at this point.
I feel like they have to do something about that because what if you were there
and then the earthquake hit?
So say if you land and as you're landing,
you're watching the runway,
ripple hide inside of [inaudible] don't,
don't,
don't.
So you skid to a stop.
He get out and you're involved in the biggest earthquake in recorded history and
then it Fukushima spouts,
lack of volcano into the sky now all the reactors and not only blown,
it creates some new reactor of its own deep in the bowels of the earth and it
mixes with lava.
Now I'm just making shit up.
Just working with Don asshole.
Yeah.
Imagine if like radio or nuclear reactors rather.
If when they went bad,
they exploded.
They just shot fire into the sky like a big zit instead of just leaking into the
earth.
Fucking everything around them.
We need to do this quick though.
Like seriously,
we need to definitely consider it and we should consider it.
Like when people talk about being preppers,
that's not going to do you any good.
If this is a real issue,
can you imagine if California had to get up and leave and what would be the next
California like?
Oklahoma's the new California now be a real problem for resources,
man.
If be real poverty problem for a long fucking time because there's a lot of
people that are not equipped,
just pack up and move their stuff.
There's a lot of people,
you know they need the job they have here.
They don't have a savings,
they don't have food,
and if they have to move to a new place,
they don't have rent money that there's not enough apartments or houses for
people.
You know.
You couldn't just take everyone on the west coast.
The West Coast is probably California,
like Los Angeles,
San Francisco.
They'll just,
those two alone have to have 30 million people.
Right.
If you had a gas,
what's the,
okay,
let's see,
what's pup population of California population.
I didn't know what this is from,
but somebody posted this on the forums.
Uh,
U s Navy Mapa Future America,
Belize shows where the coastlines would be.
Did you see this?
What does that supposedly as a US Navy map of future u s navy,
everybody please of says who though?
Like Ge,
like click on like does it,
does it have like a source Google us navy map of that's like a,
there's an old bill hex joke about California or Arizona Bay.
It was one of his,
uh,
one of his albums is titled that.
Yeah.
Okay.
The population is wow.
Ready for this?
2012 38 million,
41,000,
430.
Fuck
yeah.
That's a lot of people.
Where are they going to go?
That's like a whole country full of people.
38 million folks and they'd all have to get out.
And then on top of that,
you'd have to get rid of all the people in Oregon.
You have to get rid of all the people in Washington state.
You'd have to get rid of all the people in Alaska because they're going to take
it.
It's all going to go up by them first.
Everybody's fucked,
right?
We have spreaders of doom and gloom with zero science.
I apologize folks.
I don't know if I'm right or wrong,
but I know that scares the shit out of me.
I don't even know if it should scare the shit out of me.
A lot of people are saying that maps fake.
So of course that maps fake.
God dammit.
If the fuck does the navy know that geologists don't,
it says navy.
It's got to be right.
Our boys wouldn't lie to us when they're out there,
but fucking under some mergeable boat a,
they wouldn't lie to us about the future contours of the United States.
She's this captain.
Did you really do that?
Your instincts were so bad.
So have you been looking at any of the leaks of what Apple's about to announce
on September 10th no,
it wasn't going to be another phone.
Whoa.
Like a blueprint.
A thumbprint scan.
Yeah,
but it's no bigger.
Not Bigger.
Yeah,
they fucked up.
They fucked up.
Okay.
Bigger stuff.
Samsung got them by the Deq.
They got them by the Dick with that giant ass phone that dies in like three
seconds,
doesn't die in three seconds.
The battery life is good battery life for that Galaxy s four is supposed to be
very good.
The the number one problem with the galaxy s four seems to be people are upset
with providers software,
the shit that you get when you get it,
like if you get it from at and t or whoever,
they add a bunch of stupid shit easy for whom maybe easier for you.
Dummies like me don't want to do that.
They just want to pick up a phone and go with it.
That's why the iPhone is perfect,
but they're fucking up with these little flimsy ass screens.
I see people with that.
Galaxy s four and I get all drooly incident note note three son bigger yet.
I think it comes out real soon.
Let's stay.
Galaxy note three.
Yeah.
The girl I've been hanging out live with lately has a note and I'm always so
jealous of it because their insurance on an extra sketch.
Sure.
She's got three.
The cameras the best on the note too.
I don't know if you've ever seen the camera.
It's great.
Yeah,
that's amazing.
Okay,
so it says us release date
breakdown.
It says the launch date arrives tomorrow and that was today.
So,
um,
so tomorrow and they'll know quite a bit about the,
uh,
the,
the new one,
but they're saying that it's going to be 5.68 inches.
Jesus Christ.
Oh,
ready for this?
It can record in that Oh four k?
Yes.
That new note.
Oh,
snap.
Let's get some food.
Yeah,
we have the new a four k TV here that's been just playing puppies and Asians and
then forecast.
Yeah.
Let me,
um,
let me pull this up and make sure that that's correct,
but I'm pretty sure it is.
That's true.
I'm,
I'm sure it records in a very high definition video.
Some signals that,
let me see what it says.
This one was a preorder or g.
G Jujitsu.
Okay.
Let me see.
Galaxy note three video.
Oh my God,
they have,
is tink still sponsor here?
No,
sometimes.
Okay.
Well,
I still have the galaxy s four purple.
I didn't know they made it purple foam.
What does it mean?
It's a pair of Volvo.
It's just prayerful.
That's it.
I got sexy that galaxy notice.
Are you?
What do you print?
I like purple man.
I'm,
I'm ended up pink and purple right now because for you sex and you don't like
[inaudible] off often wrong with it.
I said you were sexy.
It's not one of the greatest things you could say about a person.
You are aware of?
Pink shirt.
Yeah,
sure it would.
I'm mailing,
is Fox on?
I wear a fanny pack.
You think it'd be afraid of pink.
Okay.
Let's see where the video HD.
See it says here full HD screen.
Ultra HD four k four k video.
Yeah.
That's incredible.
It's on your phone.
We can make videos for this TV,
four K on your phone and there's a videos of it where it's been leaked.
The size of this thing,
it's a pet tablet.
It's a fucking tablet.
Things giant for rising or anything that's going to be,
it's going to be on everybody apparently.
I wonder if it's on right now.
It comes out today,
so no,
it comes out tomorrow.
Tonight at midnight.
You're going to be out there like a dork with a camp camp set up and let's Ting
ads and your dog happy with my iPhone.
I just,
where'd you skin it?
Where's your fucking dog?
Did you get rid of that thing yet?
No.
It's packed it away.
And you give it away?
No,
no,
no.
It's at home.
You don't talk about it anymore?
Well,
I used to be your pride and joy.
I love that board with it.
I love her.
I just,
uh,
I can't,
I don't want to bring her here.
She's a little distracting.
Yeah.
She takes giant shits on the floor.
She doesn't pisses on toward Jamie when he's trying to work.
She,
he's on a Mat,
like the pee pad,
which is also great for if you're fucking a squirter or grown up here.
Shut the fuck up.
Disgusting.
Pastors saw lady at the pet store yesterday that the cutest dog.
Who's a,
um,
she has my dog.
No,
the cutest dog because my dog,
it was a American bulldog puppy.
Oh so adorable.
It was so adorable.
It was like 11 months old and it was really small.
It wasn't gonna get much bigger.
It was just the cutest,
friendliest little white dog.
So beautiful.
So weird thing that puppies are so beautiful were so strange with animals.
We have this,
these animals that we sanction and then other ones that we don't and sometimes
we sanctioned them like you're allowed to have a pet pig or some people have pet
deer.
You know that girl I'm hanging out with that she has a pet pig and a pet deer
and two of those,
three of those,
uh,
whether those cats,
the big giant real cats.
She live in an apartment in Hollywood.
It was pet deer and pet pig desert.
Does she really?
She desert rat.
Great place in the desert.
And so they have the best math out there.
Yes.
We want to go.
If you wanna be close to the Meth,
he don't want to be hiding in the city.
Cause then you have to like has to go and get distributed.
You want and get it out there fresh from the source.
That's where the meth farmers are throw out there like in between Bakersfield
and San Francisco.
A man,
they got me freaking out about this note.
They didn't have to get on Verizon.
Well it's going to come out.
They're going to announce where it's going to be out tomorrow,
but uh,
it does look pretty delicious.
But um,
uh,
Chris Ryan just gone Tang.
So many people that we recommended to with came back and said that it's a,
I love my,
they're so happy about it.
They saved money since the,
um,
the signals.
Great people say that that sprint signal is fucking good man.
It's good.
I never had problem with someone.
I tink phone.
I have problems with the actual galaxy s three,
just all these dying,
but the battery life,
it seems like this sucks it right out.
Forced quite a bit better apparently for supposed to be a masterpiece that I
have that HTC one,
but I got from my friend at Google.
Yeah,
it's in my bag here and it's pretty slick.
The thing I like about the HTC one,
first of all is the way it looks.
They have,
they built it like an iPhone.
Like it's a complete solid one piece.
Apparently Verizon has this too.
That's the music one right where it's got the speakers built into it.
Yeah.
That's the sweetest thing of all time when it comes to that.
But that's bad ass.
It's awesome.
Beaker here.
That one that you were hanging on to.
It's made for at t
and ACAC could basically socket.
I've done you before.
I don't trust you.
Every time I drive around Hollywood would death thing.
It fucking cuts out.
It just does at and t just cuts out everywhere and I,
it doesn't matter if a signal is a,
if you have a better antenna or better cell phone,
it's just not as good as Verizon in my opinion.
Well this screen is nice and everything.
I just,
you know,
I just can't get over
the software software.
Well that's the clearest,
the cleanest one.
Well you're,
well you're holding onto right there is the Google version.
That's the one that comes straight from Google play.
That doesn't have any bullshit on it.
That's an unlocked phone.
That's awesome.
So that phone can go to any GSM provider.
And what,
um,
people who,
uh,
don't know about these phones.
There's a GSM and CDMA.
CDMA is veraison and it's also sprint.
And GSM is essentially worldwide.
It's very few countries that I've ever been to other than Canada that have a,
uh,
a CDMA signal.
Most of Europe is on GSM,
like England.
When you go to England,
they're all on that.
Japan is all on that.
They're all on a different version of a cell phone.
But most of these new phones,
they're,
uh,
like the,
the Nice GSM phones or the Nice Cdma phones from Verizon or world phones,
I phones a world phone,
so it has a GSM chip in it.
So when you go to Japan and when you go to somewhere else that only has GSM,
it's still works.
Yeah.
I,
uh,
I'm excited though about September for the announcements for apple because
they're supposedly,
no,
but because you're an apple dark,
I know that they're making that the cheaper iPhone this time to also,
supposedly they're having a cheaper plastic version or I say having a gold
version supposedly.
Oh Shit.
Yeah,
bitches.
But I wonder if also to shine the IPAD mini,
I wonder if they're going to try to make it like a galaxy note phone with the
options to have a phone that hasn't really been talked about much.
They would be copying and I think that's one of the reasons why they haven't
gone with a bigger screen.
I think they're being stubborn that they're the innovators.
This is,
we found that this size is perfect.
It's perfect for your hands.
You know,
you can use it with one hand very easily and that is true,
but I use the battery pack on it,
which makes it larger anyway.
Right.
With the battery pack,
it's basically the same size as this,
but without the sexy screen.
Yeah,
because this screen is undeniably socks that you cannot fuck with that.
Did.
You just can't look at that.
Come on son.
That's things gigantic.
Die and look Kapowwe like I can get on websites with chrome socket son.
Are you kidding me?
Yeah.
But why don't you just get a mini iPad then if you went to the phone as well?
Yeah,
but I mean you could,
I can text on it.
I can put it in my pocket.
I can take pictures.
I can watch movies on it.
It's a better screen.
Yeah,
but why don't you for it just for a phone,
for phone.
Get like one of those flip phones that you could put it in your sock.
Blue.
Blue Blades.
You have two things where you could have one that does it go both better?
That doesn't make any sense.
Why wouldn't I just have this cause you cause I can go online on this screen.
It's not a preposterous experience.
There's something preposterous about scrolling side to side and an iPhone trying
to look at a whole website.
It just is this,
you don't have to do it as much.
And it's,
in my opinion,
apple fucked up.
I think they fucked up hardcore that they didn't develop a five inch screen.
Develop a five inch screen.
You fucking assholes.
It's been three years since the android people showed you that that's something
desirable and you dummies like,
no,
no.
People are quite fine.
They're very narrow.
Smaller one.
If it's in your pocket a little bit,
it's okay.
It's really good.
It works better.
It has the best software and as the best like interface.
The user interface of the iPhone is without a doubt the best experience,
but this little tiny screen could suck it all right.
This is stupid compared to this.
This is better.
This one I like better.
It's just a teeny bit of shutting the mouse on it.
You're talking about your mouth,
son.
You're talking about a very minor,
I'm talking things size.
Yeah.
Got a bag and it's not worth this software.
Its software's not that bad man.
I'm telling you this.
This,
you haven't tried this.
First of all,
this,
you don't know this one.
This is the one that has the only the Google shit.
It doesn't have any sprint shit.
Your set sprint when you started up
does against French shit on yours,
your sis Britain when he started up sun.
This one does not say sprint.
I know that's bad that this is what I'm talking to you about.
Well My,
my,
my ting one does say sprint,
but I'd hardly use that.
I love it.
I love it for pictures and videos though.
But the three I'm thinking about going with the four for um,
from my regular phone.
I'm going to try that.
I'm gonna try to galaxy s four for regular phone on Verizon.
I tried that.
How long did you try it for?
Two days.
I tried it.
I'm like,
I was all gung Ho.
I was like,
fuck.
Yeah.
Well listen man,
I saw Jay z and a video and he's using it.
So,
uh,
it's good enough for me.
Plus Jay z's a winter and a kind of feel like a winner.
I'm a winner if I'm using the same devices chassis.
That's how I feel.
Oh,
H to the O.
V I used to row snow flakes by the O.
Z.
Have you seen the video where he goes into an art gallery?
Speaking of our guy and he does wrap it in an art gallery.
We pull that up because it's kind of fascinating.
Have you seen it?
It's fascinating.
It is like something you'll go on and do it.
Look at this,
Brian.
Look how sexy all those apps.
Oh yeah,
look at that.
Oh,
you mean all of those inferior apps that are not shut your mouth,
son.
You know the fuck you're talking about.
Look at all the possible frames I have.
What are the windows that I can go to vine and look at somebody that has an
android vines compared to an iPhone.
Suck it.
Look at all the customizations and I can do go on someone vines.
I don't find kid.
You need to find sun.
No son.
I don't need to do anything.
He's where it's at.
Wilson.
I'm overexposed as it is.
You know how I know I don't like me anymore.
I'm tired of hearing me.
I hear me too much.
You hear me?
Every fucking UFC.
You listened to your [inaudible]
long when you get you again.
I'm gonna get Outta here
you go,
boy.
I listened to myself.
No,
I do have to on some occasions,
like for standup comedy,
I don't listen to these things.
I do listen to criticism like a,
I know people don't want,
they don't believe that they think like,
uh,
you know,
nobody actually appreciates criticism when they,
uh,
do podcasts or anything.
While a large percentage of it is by people that just have an opinion and their
opinion is probably,
you know,
it's probably valid.
It is to them,
everybody's experience is different.
There's things that certain people like about certain folks and their
personalities that other people don't like.
And when you take it all into consideration,
even if you don't agree with the guy,
it gives you a broader perspective of what you're actually doing.
Of the,
the,
the point of view you're actually putting out or the,
uh,
the vibe people are actually receiving when they listened to the podcast.
So even douchey criticisms have benefited me.
I really believe that even like mean nasty.
I think it's,
it's a bitter pill to swallow,
but when you get through it,
I think it's,
it benefits you.
You have a better understanding of what you are or aren't doing and it forces
you to look at what you are or aren't doing as a,
as a broadcaster,
but you don't do it.
Yeah.
That's what you're looking at me like that.
No idea what you're trying to say.
You're like,
yeah,
yeah.
Whatever.
Apple rules.
That's what I was going to say about how creepy it would be to be at this Jay z
art.
Oh,
creepy.
Yeah.
He comes up and starts rapping in your finger this,
so they're at a gallery.
He's getting ready.
I cut sleeves and this has something to do with the Samsung Galaxy s four right?
I don't know.
Yeah,
doesn't it?
I believe it has something to do with the promotion and so he's standing there
and people and he's rapping in front of people and there's like old white ladies
dancing with them.
She's like going head to head with them and dancing with them.
That's a polite way of saying she would like that Dick.
It makes you realize how an entertaining wrap really is.
I love,
what are you talking about?
All right now.
Okay.
Let me ask you this.
I think difference between seeing this yes.
And seeing the acoustic version of Everlast doing jump around.
Well,
how about he wouldn't,
he did the John Lennon saw to work class hero.
Yeah.
Dude,
come on man.
That's just,
that's for that environment.
I've been listening to his new album.
It's bone chilling.
Shit's good.
But so depressing.
Yeah,
he's a depressant fucker.
He's lived a hard life.
He's got a bluesy outlook,
but you know if you ended that music,
he's a blue man.
He's a master at it.
He's a master at that Bluesy Shit.
Fuck yeah,
he's awesome.
He's a great guy too,
man.
I really enjoy having them in here.
He came to my shows in Toronto,
came to my show in Toronto.
It was awesome.
He's a good dude.
He's so easy to hang with too.
Like he could just fit into any crowd.
He doesn't require any special attention.
He just blends in that said that depressing ass music though.
The style.
It's,
he's very just,
you know,
it's voice sounds.
Yeah.
Everything is regret.
A lot of,
lot of loneliness in there.
There's people loved that though.
They love like linking up to it,
you know?
That's why Johnny Cash Folsom prison blues is such a great song because it's
about a guy who ruined his whole fucking life.
You know,
you're singing about a guy who's watching people smoking big cigars and drinking
coffee and wishing he could be with them.
They're probably drinking coffee and smoking big cigars.
But I shot a man in Reno just to watch him.
I mean,
that's,
there's something about like ruining your life that makes for great art.
Why is that?
I don't know.
I don't know what the fuck it is about blues music.
There's something that people want to relate to about losing your life.
It's so funny.
Jamie says,
no,
you're doing a podcast right now.
Right there.
I'll change.
He's having his own little show.
What's he saying?
He says he's showing me a picture of what it looks like.
Jay Z,
uh,
looking at uh,
a galaxy s four,
and it just,
his expression on his face,
he's
like,
well he's just,
he's being um,
like sponsored by galaxy s four.
And they actually like included his album on like a million different phones
that they sold.
It was like part of the uh,
you could get the album early if he bought this phone.
Yes.
Be on it.
Yeah.
And so like people disputed that as far as like record sales go like how many,
how many records did you really sell then?
A man,
this shit ain't no iPhone dog for reals.
We're come on son.
Did you steal that from,
is that an ass Ford as Han or is that an iPhone?
It looks like an iPhone.
It looks like an Iphone,
isn't it?
They got them.
They call.
That's what the photo is about.
If you have a,
a big contract with s four.
Yeah,
you can't be seen fucking with an iPhone.
Someone could take a picture of it.
The Hey man,
look at this picture.
They give you their phone to look at and then the Paparazzi snap a shot real
quick and boom,
iPhone goes,
let's be real Jay z when no one's looking.
This is what you use
and that's true.
That's what it seems like it.
I'm sure that's what you're going to,
you're,
you should go just galaxy.
I would love,
what are you talking about man?
I'm not sponsored by nobody.
I can do whatever the fuck I want.
I know,
but that's what I'm saying is you should try to do as if you were sponsored,
see if you could do it here to put these glasses on.
Why would I do that?
These classes?
No,
not wearing those glasses and see if they help.
You know,
I read with glasses,
I read with a reading glasses would be cool if you had like red glasses.
No.
If I want to read a book and low light and have to use reading glasses,
but I can read my uh,
my laptop.
You know,
the what,
what
gets me is low light conditions.
Like I can read really good.
Like,
if I'm outside,
I could read a book with no problem.
I don't need a,
uh,
even glasses,
reading glasses.
Is driving been affected yet?
No,
no.
Driving doesn't get affected.
It's,
Steve Graham explained it to me.
He's an ophthalmologist and he said that it's a you or your brain or your,
your eyeballs rather they lose their ability to focus.
The muscle doesn't,
doesn't focus on in close things anymore and you develop near sightedness.
That's something that people,
that's wear reading glasses come from.
That's why my dad always told me to spend like 10 minutes every hour and look at
a mountain far away.
Just if you're on your computer,
just go outside and stare at something far away,
cut to,
to uh,
kind of work out that muscle into stretching out or seeing far away and seeing
close up.
Makes Sense.
It makes sense that your,
your muscle would get tired of doing the same thing over and over and over
again.
You just abusing it.
Yep.
It's also,
I think there's probably an issue with artificial light.
It's probably an issue with artificial light.
While you're looking at,
look at this motherfucker with an iPhone.
Jesus Christ,
Jz,
and he got the iPhone,
one of the white one white one black people of white limos like Eddie Griffin
used to love white limos,
get white linen white shoes.
I want to be taken around by,
I'll wipe them out.
You know they're all going to jump on that gold though.
That gold gold iPhone.
The other reason apple is releasing it,
if they do release it,
that is a smart move for the hip hop community.
You definitely want to get that.
They,
you said they had an a gold iPhone five that they gave away as a prize and one
of the MMA events,
I forget like one of the foreign MMA events.
I gave a,
I think they gave Paul Daley Gold iPhone.
That's nice.
It's silly,
right?
I mean,
what the fuck are you doing?
What if you lose it?
You're going to be so bummed out.
Lose your fucking stupid gold iPhone.
Drop your stupid goal life on this.
Well then we're going to do take the back off of it and put it on some new
innards.
You don't have to get some doctor work done.
Supposedly Apple's about to release it like a new,
a warranty program that gives you uh,
you know,
for two years your iPhone is protected up to two accidental damage things.
So like if you cracks on the ground now it's like hundreds of dollars to get,
you know,
it's not that,
but the new one's gonna let you have two cracks.
Really?
Yeah.
So two swipes.
So now I might not even be using cases anymore cause it's a sexy without the
cake.
It's,
it's very sexy about the case.
But you know,
I started using this mophie case thing.
That's the shit because you always have a second battery option.
Yeah.
There's nothing better than that man.
The idea that you can just charge that bitch up at any point in time
except the plug.
It's a plug.
Except the plug difference meaning not different.
You have to charge different anymore.
Oh it's not,
no,
no USB plug use.
If you have the micro USB,
it plugs this and it plugs the phone.
It charges bowl.
That's how it always was.
I'm talking about like,
like you know like Oh,
if you want to take the case
off and yeah,
yeah,
that's true.
But if you want to charge it,
it charges both the phone and the case with the um,
a mini USB or micro USB or whatever it is.
I think that's,
what does it say?
He sitting there with apple laptops.
Oh,
how dare you,
Jay Z,
you're allowed to have an apple laptop.
If you have a Samsung,
you don't have to use windows.
You know,
Google's coming out with their own desktop.
They don't have their own laptops now.
Yeah,
I know.
No fucking hard drives at all.
They want you to store everything in the cloud.
Such a dumb idea.
This idea of the cloud being for everything.
Yep.
Get out of my face.
What if,
anyway,
I don't have an Internet access.
I can't fucking write my paper or,
well,
not only that,
I haven't really clearly established at the NSA is looking through everything
that you do.
The NSA is going to have your cloud,
you know,
is Google going to protect your cloud from the NSA?
Really?
Sure.
No.
Where am I?
Dick pictures going.
They're going out into the universe.
I don't think it's a good idea to just store stuff in space like that unless you
don't care.
But if you have anything that's like intellectual property and like something
you're working on,
a movie that you're trying to do and you're storing it in the cloud or or
anything along those lines.
Yeah.
I mean I think,
I think it's fine for most shit,
but I'm not going to put it on my bubble photos.
I'm loud.
Oh,
I get it.
I said Dick.
And you say bottle.
Yeah.
It's funny.
Fucking child grow up.
Let's bring this thing home.
You haven't changed in three years.
Why did you think it was actually there by the way?
I said we're closing in on episode 100 it's episode 389 isn't that ridiculous?
Yeah.
Oh,
I wrote 400 that's right.
That's hilarious.
Oh,
I wrote it.
You know why?
Because it was talking and writing at the same time.
Yeah.
Edit it.
Edit the thread.
Um,
it's kind of amazing that it's almost at 489 super crazy.
If you stop buying,
think about the old days,
the old days of the snowflakes.
The next stage of this shit is that we don't have to be in the same room.
The next stage of this is that we to be in other parts of the country where to
Skype it in together.
I could already do that.
Yeah.
We were going to have to do that eventually because I'm not going to stay here.
Well,
I'm not going to stay every now that all those La Shit,
you mean radiation shit.
Yeah.
I'm,
I wasn't going to stay anyway.
I think the,
uh,
the traffic situation here is problematic.
The culture situation here is problematic.
There's a lot of things about this place I don't like.
One of the big ones is I think there's too many people and I think,
uh,
I think we devalue each other when we're there.
We're stuck in these places where there's too many people like this.
There's think the numbers are too high.
Well that in the fact that 90% of the people out here are trying to be somebody
or something,
so you're not getting normal people.
You're getting people that are usually like in the broken.
Yeah,
we're not broken.
Even like,
like when you go to high school,
you know who's in the Thespian club and who's in the the normal club.
Well,
you
know what,
look man,
there's a lot of people that are into that that I like.
You know,
there's not,
that's not all bad.
What's the bad?
To me it's not being into being a thespian.
What's bad to me is the desire for really unnecessary attention or undeserved at
attention,
I should say.
Where there's so many people that are trying to correct what they feel is an
injustice from their childhood.
That's what creates someone who wants to be famous.
That's what created me.
No doubt about it.
I had to try to work my way through that and figure it out as an adult and
adjust and evolve and I did it through martial arts and I did it through
reflection and meditation and isolation tanks and all that shit and
psychedelics,
but some people aren't interested in fixing it.
They're not interested in being balanced there.
They're interested in feeding the monster and the monster was developed when
they were children.
Almost everyone out here too.
A person has a fucked up childhood and I don't know if that's almost everyone in
America because it seems like there's a good percentage of people when you get
down to the nitty gritty and talk to them about the childhood,
there's a lot of shit they weren't happy about.
There's a lot of shit that could have been done differently,
but the opposite of that of course is that those are the most interesting people
I know.
The most interesting people I know all had fucked up childhoods.
They all had to form their own opinions of the world.
They all had to escape the pressure or the,
the,
the gravity of their environment and get out and,
and become their own individual.
And in doing so,
they developed four to two.
They develop character,
the developed creativity that some people who live in a soft,
cushy,
nerfed environment don't have to develop.
So it's almost like shielding your children from adversity can punish them in a
way.
It's almost like the only way to actually have an interesting person or develop
it,
entering interesting persons.
They have to develop,
they have to fail.
They have to try and fail and then learn why they failed and then overcome and
then deal with assholes to learn.
They don't like assholes to learn,
not to become an asshole.
See other people with you.
Don't want to see in yourself.
Correct that from yourself.
And there's like a long fucking process to making a good person.
And if you,
you know,
if a kid just grows up in Beverly hills are Brown,
a bunch of snots and they're all just doing Adderall all day and driving their
dad's BMW,
you know,
you might develop a bunch of useless fucking human beings that are never going
to be able to fix themselves.
But if you develop in a community where hard work is cherished and people
understand adversity and they appreciate,
you know,
the land that they're living on,
like a,
a cool community,
a community that has a good,
like a good,
um,
farmer's market community that people,
you know,
they,
they appreciate being there.
They work to keep environmental damage from happening to them.
They work to not pollute their work,
to
establish like a good area,
a good spot for everybody to enjoy.
That I think is the best way to do it.
But it's just once you live in a place,
it's so hard to get the fuck out really is so hard and he becomes harder when
you get older,
especially if you have children,
you know,
your children love the school they go to,
they love their friends and you're like,
hey,
yeah.
You know that person that you love more than anything in life.
Yeah.
You're not going to get to see her.
But maybe once or twice a year cause we're gonna pack up and move to Texas.
Yeah.
But usually,
I mean usually gets better,
you know,
whence United like,
have you ever moved somewhere?
I'm like,
man,
I wasn't as good as when I moved over.
You know,
live it there.
It's usually always like getting a new girlfriend.
Yeah.
You're always going up.
Usually moving down.
Well,
for me,
yes.
Um,
Colorado was a big,
I love Colorado.
I loved living there,
but there's a lot of,
you know,
when you have little kids and you're on mountain lions are eating dogs,
something fucked up about that.
It's something selfish,
man.
There's something really selfish about that.
On one hand it's like,
yeah,
well they're going to be okay if you look after them.
And the other hand it's like they might not be,
you know,
you don't want a baby getting scooped up by an eagle.
Yeah.
You'd feel like such an asshole.
You don't want to be snowed in and you can't get groceries or help.
That can happen.
That happens.
That happens in Denver once every decade or so.
They get some shit that keeps you in your house for like two weeks.
Yeah.
Fuck that.
They got seven feet of snow once.
Stop and think about that.
A fucking storm just planted itself over Denver or boulder,
I forgot where it was and just dropped seven feet of snow and these poor people
were just fucked.
The only good thing is you can melt it and drink it so you don't,
you don't have dehydration problems.
You totally drink that water.
Oh,
what the fuck?
So I posted something of the Galaxy Mega.
Oh yeah.
That's another thing they're doing.
The galaxy mega is like in between a tablet and the uh,
the note three,
that's going to be a 6.8 inches.
Is that what it is?
6.3,
6.3 inches.
That's for like guys like,
uh,
like Shaq.
Shaq could really have that no problem.
This giant hands.
See people say that,
um,
this is too big for one person for your one hand and I don't feel like it is,
I don't feel like,
uh,
the HTC one is too big for one hand.
I feel like they're going to handle that one hand,
no problems but driving and be,
I don't text and drive.
You fuckhead you should stop doing that man.
Here's what you can do easier with this.
You put the pinky underneath and it kind of does fit a little bit better in your
hand,
but you're awesome with a mophie.
You're using their,
their keyboard,
which is not as good.
I think that's great.
Keyboard's great keywords.
Keyword is just as good and the spell corrections.
Excellent.
You haven't used this,
this is your,
this is the thing about apple as opposed to a android.
One thing that they do lose on is there innovation is so far behind like as far
as like how much better new stuff is and how much they release these HTC phones
and these Samsung phones,
they're releasing them every couple of months,
like bad ass new ones with crazy new shit.
And then another one's coming down the pipe there in the middle of developing
it.
I definitely think they should expand their line to multiple funds,
which I think they're finally in doing now with this new,
like they're making the cheaper phone and maybe they might even make you talking
about apple.
So that's your team.
You just immediately go,
they,
hey man.
Hey,
you're talking about apple cause that's what's close to your heart.
I just liked the best,
you know,
I'm not good at Microsoft.
There was an article on a,
I forget what website it was on today without Microsoft flailing,
uh,
that they don't know what to do because they're,
they're new desktops.
What's that?
They bought Nokia Important Nokia guys.
They're probably like,
no,
you leave us alone.
Window is,
what are you talking about?
They want to get that money.
They're like,
good and you take are fucking dying platform here by it.
Please.
Thank you.
Give us the money.
We're done with the mobile market.
President of the company is leaving next year.
Now it's,
you know why?
Cause he's got a yacht the size of a state and it's just filled with hookers and
he's just rubbing his palms all day.
White works waiting for the one day he gets off and he gets to fucking dive into
this sea of beautiful prostitutes naked with $100 billion.
He made selling it to Microsoft,
Microsoft,
their um,
their phones are terrible.
I tried one of those windows phones.
I was like,
Jesus,
this is dog shit.
It's just so cool.
A friend of mine had one and he was trying to take a picture.
We were outside of the Ice House and he's tried to take a picture.
I call,
what are you doing with that monstrosity?
And he's like,
no,
no.
This is cool man.
He's like,
let me show you.
Let me show you what,
once you get the hang of it and he's like,
okay,
now it's here.
Nope,
hold on.
Where is it?
Uh,
yeah,
I to get the camera,
I got to,
okay.
He ain't and I was like,
oh my God,
to show me his picture.
He had to go through this whole rig tomorrow and go into his photo gallery.
I go,
you just lost me.
You lost me in.
That is shite.
You have a shite camera.
Why can't they just copy apple and then take the hit and court?
She's just,
they do it all the time.
Do it exactly the way do they do it with no variation.
Change the icon for the phone.
You know,
make it a big P for fallen a t for text.
Make it real simple like that.
See for camera,
make the icons instead of a photo of the fucking thing than it is like a photo
of a camera lens.
Make it a c.
I know what that means.
I mean it's camera.
And then I felt applicant's say shit and you can say we're innovators.
We decided that instead of having an unrecognizable image of a camera,
we went with a c for camera.
Wow.
Well what Sony's about to release a new lens for the iPhone.
That's like a professional camera lens.
Like look,
stick on the end of that.
Look at this thing like,
oh,
that's hilarious.
That's the camera lens.
That's just,
just carry a phone.
You fuck.
That's bad ass.
That's kind of crazy.
Yeah.
That's so crazy.
Yeah,
and he just snaps on your iPhone.
That is so crazy.
It
turns your iPhone into a Dslr
God fucking lenses for it.
Oh,
that's sweet.
It's never going to end.
Every year they're going to keep coming up with crazy or crazier shit.
Where's it gonna go DSLRs for your iPhone,
what is the next thing that's going to be a part of your phone?
I think the next thing is holograms.
No,
your phone is going to be more used as a remote control with the,
you know,
the apple TV stuff in the future.
And I think like these four k televisions,
you know,
they're going to,
now the phones are doing four k so you're just going to be,
you know,
just amazing.
Like,
hey,
check out what happened.
And you know,
today at the store and now you're just singing it to your phone.
I think more interactions with your TV and phone and computer.
Yeah.
Stuff like that.
No,
I hear Ya.
I think it's going to be a little ob one helped me will be one.
You're my only hope.
I think we're gonna make holograms.
I think that's coming.
I think the Hologram.
Oh,
your mom's brains all over.
I think it's,
um,
just a matter of time before we can develop something that's going to take a
three d image of something and you're gonna see a miniature version of it.
So your girl's gonna be able to send you miniature versions of her,
like fingering herself,
and you get to play it on the bed and shoot loads onto it.
Oh,
she would never do that.
Yes she would.
Dude,
she lives in the desert with monkeys and Tarzan.
Fucking snakes and shit.
All right.
Um,
let's send this,
let's wrap this bitch up.
Bring it home.
This was a silly and pointless as any podcasts we've ever done.
Thank you.
I knew I could count on you.
We've been too serious lately about a lot of shit.
Um,
sometimes yes,
sometimes no.
You know,
people,
a lot of people complained about,
uh,
the,
the TV show that I did and the,
uh,
explanations of conspiracy theories.
And that's one of the reasons why I didn't want to do those subjects in the
first place.
It's,
it's too touchy subject with people.
But I was intoxicated by the,
uh,
the ideas behind them and the idea behind behind exploring them and finding out
what people's belief systems are.
Right.
And I learned a lot.
I really did.
I learned a lot about myself and,
uh,
my own willingness to believe in shit.
But I also learned about other people's,
just it's repeatable behavior patterns.
These repeated behavior patterns where you see how they get locked into all this
crazy shit.
I'll thinking about all these crazy ideas that,
that aren't necessarily real looking for mysteries.
And for the most part it's a fucking waste of time.
The Mat,
the vast majority of all paranoid and stuff,
I think is a giant distraction.
The vast majority,
it doesn't mean there's not some possibilities,
especially for psychic powers.
The ability to see I've,
I,
you know,
I've had weird feelings in my life and they turned out to be represented in real
life.
That it's possible that,
you know,
people have some abilities that are much,
much stronger than mine.
I've had
some weird moments where I felt like I could sort of figure out that something
was wrong,
even though there's no natural indication,
but I don't have any psychic powers at all.
I have zero.
And because of these weird moments,
I always leave the door open for a possibility someday.
But like Miss Mick West said,
it's probably gonna come through technology.
It's probably the idea that a person becoming psychic,
it's probably going to get bum rushed by real psychic energy that's created by
chips before we even will,
for even going to get close to figuring out how to do it biologically on a
consistent basis.
I just think that,
um,
I think these subjects are too,
they're too toxic.
You know,
there's too much hostility involved and you get involved in these arguments that
you don't really want to be in.
I don't want to be in a chem show argument with people,
especially since that person's in his basement doing it and he has all the time
on the road to fight you with it and you're just like,
all right,
I meant show,
opened up my Twitter.
Oh Man,
I have to deal with this shit.
It's not only that,
it's also,
I don't want to be called a shill cause I'm not,
and just because we disagree with something,
I don't want you to be mad at me because it's just an idea and it's just,
it's about let's slap a fuel truck.
I get it,
I get it.
But it's also about ideas because the alien thing is just about the idea.
This is just about the idea.
There's no direct imminent threat by aliens that we need to recognize.
It's just about the idea.
And when you start talking about that idea and showing different viewpoints
like,
hey man,
maybe people were full of shit.
And then you start meeting a gang of people that are full of Shit and then you
start reporting,
hey man,
I think these guys are full of shit.
And that might be what we're seeing here.
People get so fucking mad at you.
And that was something that I kind of anticipated but didn't.
I thought of it expected that we would be able to maneuver our way around it and
we weren't able to.
So for all the people that believe in aliens,
good for you sweetie.
Good for you.
I'm not saying there's no aliens,
but you best realize that people are full of shit.
Might not be that there's no aliens,
but it might be that no one's ever seen an alien that is fucking possible to,
you've got to take that shit into consideration.
Don't get mad at me pitch,
I'd love you.
Give me a hug.
Come here,
give me a big,
a big he hug,
he freaks.
There's plenty of room in this life for love.
You don't have to create conflict.
And what I really liked about that nick,
Mick West guys,
he's not trying to start any fights with people.
He's trying to just disagree.
It does so politely.
I think that's,
we could all learn from that guy.
Alright,
you fucks.
What else could I say?
Love doesn't make sense.
Tell Jami can't get the fuck off his phone.
If you see him,
tell him pokers for idiots.
Stop it.
It's not really afraid it's,
but tell him that anyway.
Don't tell him that he's a fucking war hero.
What does that even mean?
Hey look,
we love the shit out of you guys and we'll see you Monday.
We got a,
um,
quite a few,
uh,
options for guests next week.
So it should be cool and interesting and fun and always as positive as we can
make it all right.
No inspirational speeches.
I think I've said enough today.
So I'll give you a big kiss and we'll see you soon.
Thanks to stamps.com use the code word jre.
Save yourself some cash.
Go to [inaudible] dot com use the code word Rogan and save 10% off any and all
supplements.
And we will see you this weekend.
And Braya California this Friday,
Saturday and Sunday.
Me and the lovely and talented Tony Hinchcliffe.
And if you really,
like Tony said,
you can take him home and we let you,
I've heard,
I think Colleen powder.
Oh,
I'll come with you.
We love you guys.
Bye.